merci à tous pour votre présence si
nombreuse cet après-midi pour poursuivre
notre journée sur l'Iran j'ai la chance
d'être entouré par de des intervenants
de grande qualité pour cette table ronde
et il vous en remercie sincèrement je
vais vous les présenter dans quelques
instants mais avant toute chose je
souhaiterais remercier trois femmes sans
qui cette journée n'aurait pu avoir lieu
ce sont des femmes d'engagement ce sont
des femmes de conviction elles ont
contribué à la pleine réussite de cet
événement elles ont répondu présentes
dès les premières sollicitations du
collectif et de moi-même elles ont
d'abord signé la lettre ouverte dans
Libération elles ont associé
publiquement et politiquement leur nom
au combat des Iraniens sur le sol
français je vous demande d'applaudir
maux de Gatel notre secrétaire général
Isabelle Floren notre porte-parole et
Anne-Caroline Berthet notre directrice
générale merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
le 16 septembre 2022 la mort de Massa
Amini a déclenché une immense vague de
protestation en Iran relayée par la
diaspora ici en France et j'ai eu la
chance d'être mise en relation par l'une
de mes meilleures amies présentes ici
avec le collectif femme azadie donc j'ai
deux représentantes autour de moi
aujourd'hui elles sont neufs elles
avaient une vie professionnelle une vie
personnelle avant ça elles ont tout mis
de côté pour porter le combat des
Iraniens sur le sol français mesdames
votre courage et votre détermination
sans faille force le respect et
l'admiration je ne pensais pas à
rencontrer des femmes aussi remarquables
Mona tu nous a fait pleurer tout à
l'heure en nous disant que tu ne
pourrais pas retourner en Iran pour les
obsèques de ton papa c'est ça
aujourd'hui votre vie et je pense qu'on
peut vous applaudir très très fort merci
mesdames
comme je le disais j'ai la chance d'être
accompagné d'intervenants de grande
qualité pour cette table ronde je vais
vous les présenter Armina rechi merci
infiniment d'être avec nous et d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation vous êtes
journaliste grand reporter au point vous
nous faites l'honneur de votre présence
et à travers votre expérience de
journaliste en Iran vous allez répondre
à une question que moi je me pose depuis
5 mois comment on en est arrivé là et je
vous en remercie
chaparaxalley on se connaît chape tu es
cofondatrice du collectif fameuse a dit
mais tu es aussi avocate en arbitrage
international professeur à Sciences Po
et à Paris 2 aujourd'hui sous vue du
prisme d'une Française la situation des
femmes en Iran et quelque chose d'assez
obscur et tu vas nous éclairer justement
sur les droits ou non droits des femmes
en Iran et là encore commence cette
révolution a surgit
tu es là-bas philosophe d'origine
iranienne tu as tu es vice-présidente du
conseil scientifique du fond Ricard tu
nous partagera tes réflexions autour de
cette révolution
Manelli co-fondatrice du collectif
également tu es consultante en stratégie
et la question que tout le monde se pose
aujourd'hui c'est quelle sera la suite
de cette révolution et tu essaiera de
nous éclairer
il y a you don't speak French Sow i am
going twin traduction
[Applaudissements]
alors rentrons dans le vif du sujet
Armin on voit que la mobilisation depuis
quatre mois et demi continu
mais qui également la répression du
gouvernement se poursuit se durcit on a
vu récemment qu'un couple qui a posté
une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux en
train de danser a été condamné à 10 ans
de prison
qu'est-ce qui dans l'histoire de de
l'Iran dans la situation géopolitique
fait qu'on en est arrivé à cette
situation et comment on en est arrivé là
en fait
bonjour à tous ça fonctionne déjà merci
et merci beaucoup de au modem aux
collectif Amazonie pour pour cette
journée
merci de m'avoir invité et je suis très
très heureux d'être ici parmi vous je
pense que cette question très vaste qui
qui a été posée mais en fait la réponse
est assez facile à mon sens moi je vais
essayer de vous parler de mon expérience
en tant que journaliste
franco-iranien français iranien se
posant des deux nationalités
je prétends pas détenir la vérité sur ce
qui se passe sur place en revanche j'ai
pu me rendre en Iran à plusieurs
reprises m'y installer en tant que
correspondant en 2005
c'est là que j'ai commencé en fait ma
carrière de journaliste dès que je suis
sorti d'école
et jusqu'ici en tout cas avant de me
rendre en Iran bon j'avais déjà été à
plusieurs reprises auparavant mais
l'Iran en tant que Français français
d'originéérienne c'est un pays qui me
faisait peur pour moi l'Iran c'était la
Romani c'était l'assassinat de l'ancien
Premier ministre chapeau Bastia
martial pardon en France assurer début
des années 90 un régime terroriste un
régime que je voyais à travers des films
comme par exemple jamais sans ma fille
c'est un pays qui me faisait peur et
j'avais peur je ne sais pas pourquoi
alors mes parents n'étaient pas
forcément politiquement engagés de ce
bien le même sort
c'est un film aussi que un film pardon
un pays
qui
s'est présenté aux Français par le biais
d'une oeuvre Persepolis
qui est une offre très touchante de
Marjane Sète rapide qui a montré d'une
certaine manière que il y avait un
régime il y avait également une
population
qui avait fait une révolution contre le
chat
dictateur pour certains autocrates pour
d'autres modernistes en tous les cas
mais qui avait
provoqué en tout cas susciter contre une
vague mouvement de contestation avec des
islamistes avec des libéraux avec des
islamons marxistes
et qui ont qui ont provoqué qui ont
favorisé en tout cas sa chute en 1979
au départ moi c'est mon avis je commande
ce que je pense d'après d'après tout ce
que j'ai pu lire ce n'était pas une
révolution islamique une révolution
contre le chat après moi une
l'une des premières si ce n'est la
première révolution dans le monde
musulman premier printemps en fait on va
dire printemps Perse
et qui a aboutit donc voilà à la chute
d'un dictateur soutenu par l'Occident
car pour beaucoup le chat était présenté
comme en tout cas le fidèle allié si ce
n'est le servant des Occidentaux bon
c'est un peu plus complexe que ça
mais dans tous les cas ça chute a
bénéficié à une force qui était la plus
mobilisée en tout cas
la plus présente au dernier jour de la
révolution dans la rue savoir les
islamistes qui se sont ensuite emparés
du pouvoir et en instauré une république
islamique basée sur la charia
qui n'était pas forcément ce qui avait
été annoncé au départ notamment par la
comédie du temps où il était
réfugié pendant quelques mois nos offres
le château cette commune des Yvelines
avec à l'époque la bienveillance
les autorités françaises et mais
également avec qui suscitait pouvait
susciter l'admiration de certains
membres de la couche de l'époque bref en
tout cas tout ça pour dire que c'était
pas le plan et quand en réalité la
résistance à la République islamique
a débuté dès le lendemain de la
révolution avec les premières
manifestations lorsque
unie qui avait promis qu'il s'en irait
dans sa mosquée à Rome ville au centre
de l'Iran a décidé de mettre en pratique
de prendre de son pari du pouvoir et de
mettre en pratique une théorie qu'il
avait bien signifié et écrite pendant de
ses livres à savoir level a été Faris
c'est-à-dire que le pouvoir du Guide
suprême à savoir que en Iran c'est un
religieux qui préside au destinée de
l'État donc la religion et le politique
sont sont fusionnés et ça ça va c'est
contraire en fait à l'islam cheat parce
qu'on est dans l'Islam on a donc les
sunnites majoritaire on a également
l'islamshit avec un clergé mais c'était
horrible à l'état et Farid elle est
vraiment
exclusive à l'Iran c'est à dire que dans
l'Islam chie traditionnel en Irak
les clercs ne s'occupent pas de
politique bref
on fait un grand saut je vous ai parlé
de Persépolis moi il y a quelque chose
que j'ai adoré dans ce film c'est qu'il
a il a montré voilà aux Français même
aux yeux du monde entier que le peuple
iranien était différent de des religieux
qui les gouvernaient qui avaient une
résistance très très tôt qui s'est
installée qui s'instaurait contre les
mollets qui malheureusement elle a été
réprimé dans le sang
le lendemain de la Révolution favoriser
en ce sens également par l'invasion de
Saddam Hussein donc de l'ancien
président irakien donc de l'Iran soutenu
à l'époque par l'Occident et également
les monarchies Arabie Golfe et qui a
permis justement au régime de bandir
l'excuse de cette guerre pour réprimer
d'autant plus les forces leurs anciens
alliés à l'intérieur du pays
tout ceci pour dire quoi si pour dire
que quand je me suis installé en Iran
2005 je me suis rendu compte j'étais en
fait sous le choc en réalité le choc
avait déjà commencé auparavant lors de
mes nombreux allers-retours avec ce pays
mais je voyais un
peuple un pays totalement différent de
ce que on pouvait en penser ce qu'on
pouvait en voir dans les médias savoir
que peut-être que naïvement en tout cas
au départ je pouvais m'attendre à la
Corée du Nord à une vulgaire dictature
avec
toute une population ou pas mais en fait
pas du tout
au-delà de la chaleur légendaire des
Iraniens qui vous appellent mon chéri
Aziza m'a tous les coins de rue ça
débattait ça débattait dans les taxis ça
débattait dans la rue le voile
obligatoire depuis l'instauration de la
République islamique alors encore une
fois c'était pas le plan et bah il était
porté mais il était porté de façon assez
assez large
avec des cheveux rebelles des passants
de part et d'autre du foulard
et pour vous dire la vérité j'ai passé
deux années exceptionnelles en tant que
correspondant pour la presse française
en Iran
et ce qui me frappait le plus alors ça
peut vous choquer aujourd'hui regarde ce
qui se passe actuellement de la
répression terrible
mais j'avais vraiment le sentiment qu'il
faisait bon vivre en Iran alors
attention il fait bon vivre en Iran
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que je
suis peut-être un lobbyiste du régime où
je ne sais quoi d'autre non
j'espère pas mais ce que je voulais dire
par là c'est que
c'est un pays jeune
avec profusion de sentiments
à tous les coins de rue avec une
jeunesse extrêmement mûre mature
beaucoup plus mûre que moi à l'époque
j'avais quoi à 22 ans
il y avait des journaux certes avec de
nombreuses lignes rouges
il y avait
de Téhéran à Rome en passant par Chiraz
machad
a
Kurdistan une énorme opposition un
écrantement une énorme opposition au
régime
pas forcément de volonté révolutionnaire
pourquoi c'est ce que me disait les
jeunes à l'époque c'est déjà un on n'a
pas envie de mourir dans la rue se faire
rabattre dans le sang
on a peur d'une guerre et c'était encore
quelques années avant et printemps arabe
et notamment l'exemple de la Syrie
d'ailleurs dans lequel l'Iran est lié
l'Iran dès le premier jour à envoyer sur
place aux côtés de Bachar el-Assad de
son régime
des Gardiens de la Révolution l'armée
idéologie du régime pour aider l'armée
syrienne et ses services de
renseignement à mater la répression dans
le sang
la guerre et la connaissait les Iraniens
il a vécu huit ans imposé par Saddam
Hussein et des de l'Occident
avec d'ailleurs utilisation l'époque
d'armes chimique qui était loin
d'être décrié en Occident et en passant
ce n'est pas le sujet on avait
mais pas forcément de l'ont été
révolutionnaire parce que et ce qui est
arrivé souvent c'est que nos parents ont
fait la révolution en 2005 ma génération
d'avant avait fait la révolution et
qu'elle avait eu pire
une certaine manière en ce sens l'Iran
j'ai eu le sentiment qu'il a joué un
rôle de laboratoire du Proche et
Moyen-Orient à l'époque je me souviens
bon j'ai fait par ailleurs enfin ça je
raconte ça dans mon premier livre mais
c'est pas c'est le but c'est pas de
raconter tout ça mais j'ai fait dans le
nord de Téhéran c'était choquant à
l'époque des fêtes comme jamais j'en ai
faite en France où l'alcool coule à flot
il y avait de la drogue ou le foulard
disparaissait totalement des femmes
arrivées parfois en chadore dans une
fête et en ressortait en mini-jupe bref
je veux pas dire que l'Iran est un pays
libre mais je veux dire que pour un
occidental qui est arrivé de France
c'était choquant cette liberté de ton
aussi surtout
à l'époque on venait de sortir alors les
Iraniens étaient
quand même assez frustré chaude et
pourquoi parce que les Iraniens cette
année auparavant donc en 1997
suite à n'est pas pardon avait porté
massivement leur voix en faveur du
président réformateur
en Iran il faut faire bien faire la
distinction en tout cas au cours des 40
4 dernières années entre conservateurs
et formateurs
en tout état de cause au lendemain de la
guerre Iran Irak
le mot d'ordre ça a été la
reconstruction du pays et le champ
politique en Iran en tout cas autorisé
par la République islamique c'était des
membres du régime c'est à dire que si on
était contre le régime on n'avait pas le
droit de citer ou c'était la prison ou
l'exil qu'on choisit malgré beaucoup
beaucoup de pesants
encourager d'ailleurs en sens par la
République islamique et donc dans le
champ politique il y avait une lutte
entre réformateurs
partisan comme son nom l'indique de
réforme
une ouverture sociétale sociale
terme de liberté individuelle à
l'intérieur du pays
mais également d'une ouverture d'un
dialogue vis-à-vis de l'Occident
dans le but de faire perdurer ce régime
la différence avec les conservateurs
c'est quoi c'est que le conservateurs
ont exactement le même but faire perdre
durée ce régime mais ils n'ont pas
confiance en l'Occident
quand ils accusent qu'ils accusent
d'ailleurs pas forcément à tort d'avoir
aidé ça en vert l'Iran
que eux la révolution c'est avant tout
des fondamentaux
la lutte contre l'anti impérialisme
américain au sioniste comme il l'appelle
l'aide au désodérité
et des valeurs extrêmement
conservatrices inscrite gravé dans la
Constitution basée sur l'islam
et donc en fait au cours des multiples
années on a eu
à chaque fois une sorte de d'alternance
entre des élections en Iran qui sont
alors ça aussi il faut leur appeler en
Iran il y a des élections au suffrage
universel ce qui est qui n'est pas le
cas tous les pays de la région notamment
nos grands alliés Arabie golf
mais
la spécificité iranienne c'est que ces
élections en fait
elles sont
dès le départ en fait elles sont elles
sont faussées pourquoi parce que la
moindre candidature doit être filtrée
par un conseil qui s'appelle le Conseil
des gardiens de la Constitution qui
vérifie
de la compatibilité de chaque candidat
avec la Constitution avec la République
islamique et dont la moitié des juges
directement nommés par le guide suprême
et l'autre moitié indirectement nommé
par le guide suprême par le biais du
chef de l'autorité judiciaire lui-même
nommé par le guide suprême tout cela
pour dire quoi pour dire que en Iran
les élections chaque fois qu'il y a eu
des élections que la population avide de
changement il y a cru elle a massivement
porté son vote sur les candidats
réformateur l'élection de Mohamed ami en
1997 a été vécue comme une grande
surprise y compris à l'époque par le
guide suprême qui ne s'y attendait pas
sur candidat étant vaincu et premier
tour et à l'époque en tout cas il
n'avait pas suffisamment
centralisé le pouvoir autour de sa
personne
pour s'opposer à ce résultat-là donc il
a accepté mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait en
malin qu'il est il a passé les deux
mandats devant ma trotami à lui mettre
des bâtons dans les rues
lui empêchant de mettre en place la
moindre de ses réformes et surtout ce
mot à mettre tamis lorsqu'il y a eu des
émeutes qui est manifestations
pro-démocratiques au sein d'université
Terran 1999 n'a pas eu le moindre mot
pour la répression déjà sanglante à
l'époque
donc au bout de ces deux premiers
mandats les Iraniens se sont dit mais
attendez on s'est fait réellement avoir
en fait les réformateurs et les
conservateurs sont les deux pièces d'une
même les deux pardon les deux faces
d'une même pièce
donc ils n'ont pas voté en 2005 et en
2005 c'est l'époque où un président du
qu'un candidat ultra-conservateur que
personne ne connaissait présentait un
peu comme le balayeur de la nation très
populiste dans ses slogans marcinage que
l'on connaît ici pour cette RIB enflammé
contre Israël et propulsé à la
présidence
bénéficiant déjà à l'époque de fraude
électorale en 2005
mais également du repoussoir de son
candidat du candidat modéré se retrouve
en face à lui
rushmira sanjani
ancien président de la République
islamique qui a épousé peu à peu le camp
des réformateurs mais qui est également
en Iran un peu le symbole de la
corruption car il s'est beaucoup enrichi
lui et sa famille au cours de toutes ces
années là
attention massive des Iraniens
fraude organisée par le régime
et une viscérale vis-à-vis de la
générations
va être élu à la surprise générale
ça va être deux années deux années
pardon
pour la population iranienne
reprise du programme nucléaire cette RIB
enflammée quand Israël
populisme au niveau des politiques avec
reversement
de l'argent du pétrole à l'époque le
baril était un cours très élevé aux
petits peuple d'Iran et surtout
fermeture
des petites libertés de l'espace société
à l'Iranien avec nombreuses libertés que
les Iraniens perdent avec notamment un
exemple que l'on connaît bien
multiplication des brigades de la police
des mœurs qui déjà
était présent dans la rue en Iran
les Iraniens conscients de ce recul en
termes de démocratie vont quatre ans
plus tard à la fin du premier mandat
massivement voté pour
les adversaires de la présidence
fraude à nouveau tout autre couleur dès
le premier tour c'est le mouvement vers
de contestation à l'époque les Iraniens
descendant la rue des millions de cette
ce scrutin que l'on l'estime à raison
frauduleux
c'est le slogan qu'on reconnaît tous où
est mon vote là
à l'époque en tout cas au début de ces
manifestations est un slogan
réclamant pour la réforme réclamant où
est
le vote de temps d'iranien qui ont obéi
aux règles fixées par la République
islamique qui s'y sont tenus et qui
malgré tout
se retrouvent
donc c'est un premier coup extrêmement
dur pour les réformateurs en Iran la
répression va être féroce au moins 150
morts certainement bien plus c'est là
qu'on se souvient tous des images d'une
Médor Solton cette jeune iranienne
dans la rue abattu par un tir de sniper
qui se vide de son sang
devant les yeux du monde entier à
l'époque en 2009 deux ans avant le
printemps arabe ce sont les Iraniens qui
vont être un des premiers pays à
utiliser massivement les réseaux sociaux
déjà à l'époque pour diffuser leurs
images
il va s'en suivre 4 années sous main de
l'extrêmement extrêmement difficile avec
le retour de sanction
de la communauté internationale
notamment sur la question du nucléaire
en 2013 le l'Iran est un pays exemples
les Iraniens sont désespérés
l'Occident à tout prix empêcher l'Iran
d'avoir la bombe mais n'y arrive pas et
c'est là que le véritable maître des
jeux en Iran le guide suprême
arrive d'une certaine manière à retomber
sur ses pattes
et sort de son chapeau
un conservateur
ancien aux dirigeants
au moment de la guerre et en Irak à San
Rohani qui va être converti en
conservateur pragmatique et qui va nous
faire des promesses de liberté la
population iranienne
qui est déjà sous l'eau
ça va être le candidat parfait parce
qu'à nouveau les Iraniens
qui ont compris ce que là ce que ça
engage engendrait de ne pas de
s'abstenir à voter dans ces élections
même si celle-ci sont possédés le départ
ont à nouveau porter à la présidente du
pays à San Juani à l'époque tout le
monde est content dans la rue
les Occidentaux qui vont pouvoir
négocier
un accord sur le nucléaire iranien
malheureusement en Iran
comme j'ai déjà expliqué mais peut-être
pas en ces termes on a donc une
république islamique République pouvoir
qui tient sa légitimité du peuple
islamique tient directement ça
légitimité de Dieu dans les faits
le président de la République n'a aucun
pouvoir en Iran c'est un exécutant sort
de Premier ministre
qui ne doit même pas les ministres les
plus importants c'est toujours le guide
suprême donc exactement comme otami
avant lui Rohani ne va pas pouvoir
mettre en place son programme
et liberté ne vont pas s'améliorer bien
au contraire
mais on peut quand même
admettre qu'il a réussi
favoriser en tout cas avec l'accord du
Guide a signé un accord un accord sur
l'année dernière qui instauré en Iran le
plus le système de contrôle le plus
important à ce jour par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique on
est en 2015 à ce moment-là moi
personnellement
j'ai pu retourner en Iran parce que
pendant 9 ans je n'avais pas pu
malheureusement je n'y étais pas
autorisé
et je me souviens de la de l'euphorie
dans la rue de la vague des sports
immenses des Iraniens
qui sont là dans la rue ont certaines
déjà de joie prennent leur foulard et le
fond bienvolté dans les airso
c'est pas l'acceptation par ses iraniens
de la République islamique
il les déteste
mais on est comme dans un vieux couple
qui n'arrive pas à divorcer qui n'est
pas en possible en position de divorcée
pour tel ou quelque soit la raison et
qui dit à ces mots-là qu'il est dirige
vous nous détestez on vous déteste
mais comme on n'a pas le choix avançons
ensemble et aujourd'hui on est
extrêmement content que les entreprises
occidentales notamment françaises mais
pas que reviennent en république
islamique
le régime aura d'autres choix que de
s'ouvrir pour notre plus grand bien
malheureusement ce conte de fait ne va
durer
que deux trois ans à l'époque je m'en
souviens très bien je m'en souviens de
temps plus que je n'étais pas à
l'origine de ça mais au sein de mon
hebdomadaire Le Point
parce que c'est à la mode parce que time
l'a fait aussi avant nous et parce que
c'est dans l'air du temps
on va te faire une couverture intitulée
Le Nouvel An
avec voilà l'archétype iranienne au
foulard tombant avec les cheveux qui
dépassent on parle on se met à nouveau à
reparler de la paire
de des histoires
tumultueuses entre l'Iran et l'Occident
il y aura elles vont en poupe à l'époque
les Français se précipitent sur place et
il est dingue vraiment dingue
de se rendre compte à quel point
tous mes collègues amis français
uniquement français pas franco-iranien
ou iranien qui se rendent en Iran
reviennent choquer à chaque fois sans
exception on va peut-être 98% des gens
qui me disent mais c'est dingue ce n'est
pas du tout le pays que je vois dans les
médias
mais c'est dingue le peuple iranien
extrêmement attachant
le régime a l'air dur mais bon on le
voit pas trop dans la rue
et franchement j'ai passé deux semaines
bon il s'agit de vacances en deux
semaines ou alors des gens qui qui sont
plus longtemps mais j'ai passé deux
années trois années pendant deux trois
semaines inoubliables
c'était le cas de longue date des
Français retraités qui seront en Iran
faire le tour de Persepolis
il y a Chiraz voir les beautés de la
Perse en thé islamique poste islamique
poste République en tout cas poste
invasion de l'islam on va dire plutôt
mais c'est également le cas de plus en
plus de jeunes Français un peu bobo
parisien bordelais au toulousain qui
prennent un sac à dos vont en Iran et se
disent mais c'est dingue de voir à quel
point en Iran les gens viennent vers toi
communique on vit les changer de déteste
pas les occidentaux
et comme il déteste le régime
il va y avoir à l'époque
je reviens justement la couverture du
point je me souviens très bien de cette
journaliste une amie qui me dit mais
tout le monde est content à l'époque de
cette coupe du français
avec moi
les diplomates iraniens les diplomates
français aussi parce que s'ils
connaissent l'Iran et sauf que c'est un
grand pays une grande culture et que
c'est un peu plus extrêmement attachant
j'ai juste une personne qui me qui me
dit vraiment je me cite à l'époque tu te
fous de notre gueule je comprends pas
comment ça mais en quoi la situation
s'est améliorée en Iran mais quelle
nouvelle Iran mais tu te fous de nous
vraiment
comment ça mais regarde en plus j'essaye
même si la couverture est très positive
la couverture de ce magazine
pour cette constater voilà j'ai fait mon
boulot je raconte quand même comment la
religion vers la révolution est en train
de dévorer ses enfants en suivant
notamment l'exemple de
Hassan Remini le petit-fils de la Romani
qui aujourd'hui est voué aux gémonie
parce qu'il a épousé le camp réformateur
et son fils a lui-même donc le petit
fils on parle dans le l'arrière
petit-fils de la Roumanie qui est devenu
une star un peu
certes claire mais Claire éclairé soit
un mauvais jeu de mots
adepte d'Instagram de et des
technologies
rien y faire cette journée se dit
regarde rien n'a changé sur Oignies
certes je fais me regarde le voile est
encore davantage en train de tomber si
bien que dans les grandes villes du pays
beaucoup de femmes le portent plus ou
mal
mais ils me disent mais c'est pas la
question le voit le voile sans symbole
mais il y a de choses beaucoup plus
importantes comme de liberté politique
la situation des journalistes le droit
économique et social
trois politique avant tout
je sens quand même prendre un
mécontentement et bien évidemment à
l'époque en tout cas en 2015 c'est une
entente de circonstances qui a commencé
très bien ce que pense quand même une
grande majorité de la population il va
arriver il va y avoir un tournant en
2018 et ensuite d'ailleurs toujours pas
remis qui est le retrait de l'accord sur
le
par Donald Trump le président américain
tout le monde s'y attendait à l'époque
mais personne ne comprend
parce que on peut penser ce que veut ce
qu'on veut de ce régime mais Dieu sait
qu'il est actif pas forcément de la
façon plus positive au Moyen-Orient mais
sur la question de nucléaire jamais un
pays n'a été
tu as subi autant de contrôle de la part
de l'organe
dont c'est le métier à savoir l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
dépêché en Iran c'est nombreux
inspecteurs
et les 11 rapports si je me souviens
bien de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique sont formelles l'Iran
respectait cet accord c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque beaucoup de gens tu disais que
c'est l'Iran qui allait essayer de
tricher mentir
on peut dire qu'ils l'ont pas fait mais
en tout cas les rapports sont formés
et Donald Trump qui juge que cet accord
est un mauvais accord je cite le pire
jamais négocié
se dit en grand business mankiller on va
en négocier un autre
on va imposer une pression maximale sur
les rangs pour avoir un meilleur accord
qui répond notamment au revendications
des pays voisins de l'Iran allié des
États-Unis Israël les Émirats arabes
l'Arabie Saoudite
il a imposé contre l'Iran plus de 1500
sanctions économiques
qui ont provoqué une inflation record en
Iran
bien évidemment les sanctions touchées
les intérêts du régime mais elles ont
également touché les Iraniens on leur
dit quotidienne ne serait-ce que par
rapport à la déviation d'évaluation de
la monnaie le tout le monde qui a perdu
90% de sa valeur par rapport à dollar au
dollar et l'inflation qui en découle
mais lorsque je suis retourné quelques
mois après cet accord en Iran j'ai été
en fait j'ai reçu une nouvelle claque
peut-être encore plus chaud qu'avec la
première
j'ai fait à cette époque là avec ma
femme le tour de Lyon
et en Iran
mon hobby favori c'est parler avec les
gens discuter parce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression que les Iraniens sont
sous sans avoir bu de l'alcool en fait
c'est son bol comme on dit en personne
ils sont vraiment ils ont envie de
parler ils ont envie de discuter vous
voient pas comme un billet de banque sur
sur pattes peut-être parce qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément l'habitude des touristes
non plus ils sont diablement attachants
et à l'époque j'arrive un peu un peu
timide j'en suis presque à m'excuser
en tant que européen
de ne pas avoir pu empêcher ce retrait
unilatéral de la console nucléaire
iranien et le rétablissement des
sanctions
et c'est vrai que
d'un côté on a quand même un régime que
l'on connaît tous qui a respecté un
accord je ne parle bien du nucléaire pas
d'autres questions et de l'autre
un président américain qui ne l'a pas
fait et qui décide d'imposer des
fonctions record contre l'Iran non pas
pour ce qu'il a fait mais pour ce qu'il
est
un régime qui soutient des mouvements
terroristes opposés aux États-Unis dans
la région bref
qu'elle n'est pas ma surprise à l'époque
de me rendre compte que les gens en fait
majorité 90% des gens avec lesquels je
parle de tout class social de tout étage
qui me disent mais t'as pas intérêt à
compris toi encore une fois encore une
fois parce que rien compris je dis
j'aime ne pas comprendre qu'est-ce qui
commence mais l'Iran à respecter un
accord mais n'importe quoi tu connais
pas les mots là oh là là mais c'est
l'Iran qui exporte le terrorisme dans
toute la région je vais très bien je dis
pas le contraire mais en ce qui concerne
le nucléaire
les centrifugeuses elles sont à l'arrêt
l'uranium Richie il a été envoyé en
Russie la bombe l'Iran l'a toujours pas
mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes mais
n'importe quoi tout ce qui nous arrive
c'est à cause des mots là tous les jours
on en peut plus on n'a pas de liberté on
en a marre on aurait juste que la
gestion économique est mauvaise fumée
c'est quand même les fonctions
américaines qui disent certaines
manières on peut le dire on pour
conséquence d'aggravation de conditions
de vie
mais tu es mais tu es pour eux en fait
tu es un agent du régime ou quoi là je
veux plus te parler et ça a été ça
tout le long lors de ce voyage qui a
duré trois semaines quatre coins du pays
et là je me suis dit
il est malin ce Trump
ça serait pas que je dirais ça un jour
je le pense pas fondamentalement mais je
me dis il est malin
il décide pour des raisons qui lui sont
propres de se retirer d'un accord il
pousse une pression maximale contre
l'Iran
et c'est
au mot là qu'on veut le peuple iranien
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
alors pour ça que je quand je dis qu'il
était malin il faut un peu prendre
quelques pincettes car aujourd'hui dans
cette constater 5 ans après le retrait
de l'accord l'Iran n'a jamais été aussi
proche de la bombe donc ça n'a pas
forcément marché en revanche en revanche
alors que les sanctions touchent
la population parce qu'aucune entreprise
étrangère aujourd'hui ne va investir en
Iran de peur d'avoir d'être sur le coup
de sanctions extraterritoriale
américaine
les Iraniens aujourd'hui
sont complètement désespérés
donc
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui en fait était
écrit et le dernier acte de ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui il a lieu
en 2021 lors de la présidentielle
après deux mandat
alors que beaucoup d'Iraniens avaient à
nouveau en 2017
réélu grand très bien
dans les bureaux de vote il était là
entre deux mots on préfère on préfère le
moins pire on a vu ce que ça donnait de
ne pas voter on va quand même voter pour
cette personne là on va voir
4 années plus tard on s'est rendu compte
que ils se sont rendus compte et pas pu
tenir ses promesses soit parce qu'il
n'avait pas les coups d'étranges vous
avez des guides ce qui est vrai soit
parce qu'il était lui-même un des pions
essentiel de la République islamique ce
qui est vrai aussi
même si le débat en Iran dans le cas de
fixé par la République islamique existe
une réalité aussi et parfois même prévu
le virulent
en 2021 le guide suprême
qui a vraiment concentré tous les
pouvoirs réussi à concentrer tous les
pouvoirs autour de sa personne
si bien au niveau du judiciaire qui est
suprême
au niveau du législatif aujourd'hui qui
entre les conservateurs mais surtout le
corps des Gardiens de la Révolution
l'armée biologique de la République
islamique pour les généraux lui sont
totalement inféodés l'armée iranienne
également dans le but est pourtant de
protéger les frontières de l'Iran il y a
différents le but est de protéger les
régimes
tous sont choisis selon
leur fidélité au guide et non pas pour
leur compétences
le dernier acte c'était d'avoir de se
débarrasser des derniers réformateurs
qu'ils ont bien usé jusqu'à la moelle
pour avoir à la tête de l'exécutif
un président
ultra conservateur sur la même ligne
guide c'est ce qui est arrivé ils n'ont
pas fait semblant jamais les Iraniens
aussi peu voté lors d'une présidentielle
et jamais des candidats conservateurs on
va dire on a même plus on en est même
plus au conservateur modéré mais
pragmatiques n'avaient autant été éjecté
par les gardiens de la Constitution
avant même le vote 99% des candidatures
si bien que tous ceux qui suiviront à
l'époque se sont dit mais c'est
suicidaire en fait
comme stratégie qui aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de faire valoir et formateurs qui
sont réels
on était on se demande on était tous en
tant que
journaliste chercheur spécialiste de
l'Iran à se demander quand ça allait
éclater
les gens leur dire les plus modérés au
sein même du régime que je côtoie
également
du tout en tout cas je pouvais aller en
Iran
me disait à l'époque il va y avoir des
il va y avoir des il va y avoir des
manifestations mais le régime
arrivera que son analyse allait réprimer
dans le sang et aller faire taire
il ne suffisait en Iran que d'une
étincelle
c'est ce qui est arrivé avec la mort
tragique de maçonnerie
pour un voile mal porté
mais forcé de constater que à sa mort
lors de ses funérailles de jour après
dans sa ville de sarcase dans le
Kurdistan iranien c'est bien les slogans
morts à la République islamique est mort
ramené le guide suprême qui était scandé
et non pas mort la police des mœurs mort
aux ascenseur à mini
quoi que ce soit donc on peut s'empêcher
de constater une terrible fuite en avant
d'un régime dont la seule réponse
aujourd'hui et la répression
et comme vous le disiez donc au début de
cette conférence en fait certaines
manières cet été écrit ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui c'est tragique
aujourd'hui on est le contestation
toujours aussi vive répression féroce
rendez compte aujourd'hui on a eu 4
romanations en quatre exécutions pardon
de personnes qui étaient condamnées à
mort suite à des procès des manifestants
si ça des procès à des simulacres de
procès
on a une contestation qui intacte et qui
demande qu'avec la terre à nouveau
le prochain rendez-vous a été donné à
l'occasion de comme les alcools
difficiles aujourd'hui de sortir dans la
rue il a été donné à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire
de la République islamique le 11 février
prochain
que de nombreux manifestants appellent à
détourner en manifestation contre le
régime
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une impasse
clairement
entre une des manifestants qui
n'arrivent pas en tout cas tout de suite
à renverser le régime que rien n'est pas
tombé il n'est pas sur le point de
tomber
mais aussi un régime qui malgré sa force
son appareil répressif donc il a
l'apanage n'arrive pas à venir à bout à
étouffer la contestation
il ne suffit du besoin d'être
spécialiste de l'Iran ou même d'être
iranien pour se rendre compte que à
terme et dans un
futur proche de régime est condamné
vu que
comme la vue d'ailleurs beaucoup de
diplomates étrangers cette fois présents
en Iran
il s'est séparé de sa propre population
et notamment de sa jeunesse
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse Armin
on voit comme vous le disiez qu'il
suffisait juste d'une étincelle pour que
voilà tout explose sans faire de mauvais
jeux de mots cependant ce qui est
caractéristique de ce mouvement en Iran
c'est quand même que c'est un combat
féminin si on peut dire ça ce sont les
femmes qui ont d'abord relancé le
mouvement en marchant cheveux au vent
dans les rues de Téhéran comme le dit
golfifté Farahani c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que des
hommes meurent pour la liberté des
femmes c'est un elles ont commencé le
combat elles ont été soutenues par les
hommes mais c'est en effet elle qui sont
au centre de ce combat
chiaparac est-ce que tu peux nous
expliquer nous française on a un peu du
mal à concevoir ce que c'est que d'être
une femme en Iran et qu'elle est du coup
le statut de la femme en Iran
merci Aurélie
ça fonctionne
très bien
alors
il a raison Armin quand il dit que quand
on y va comme ça en vacances on peut
être un peu surpris après moi la
première fois que j'ai été c'était en 90
c'était juste après la guerre Iran Irak
et j'ai trouvé ça terrorisme j'étais une
gamine je devais déjà porté le voile
j'avais à peine 10 ans
on avait ces femmes habillées en noir
qui nous disaient remettons voile
becache Paris
j'étais terrorisée parce que je me
disais à chaque coin de rue ça peut être
un coup de fouet ça peut être quelqu'un
qui qui m'embarque et ou qui embarque ma
mère
ma première expérience c'était en 90 et
ma deuxième et dernière expérience
c'était en 2008
donc c'était juste après à Mazin et Jade
et je me souviens très bien on est
arrivé en Iran on avait demandé les
dress code à nos cousins sur place et il
nous avait dit
tu peux me t'habiller comme tu veux faut
juste avoir un manteau on appelle ça un
manteau qui arrive à peu près au genou
et puis bon le voile tu verras c'est
assez libre sauf que quand on est à
l'époque vous vous souviendrez peut-être
en 2008 la grande mode ici comme là-bas
c'était de porter ses bottes au dessus
de son legging et donc et c'était
totalement permis sauf que j'arrive
là-bas et au bout de trois jours c'est
plus du tout permis à ma dîner jade
avait interdit enfin je sais pas si
c'était lui d'ailleurs mais ils ont
interdit spécifiquement cette tenue là
et donc rebelote tétanisé comment
va-t-on s'habiller donc moi j'ai
toujours enfin les deux fois où j'y
étais c'était avec c'était
systématiquement avec la peur au ventre
parce que quand même depuis 79 c'est un
véritable apartheid de genre qui est
pratiqué et forcément en tant que jeune
fille ou en tant que femme je les
ressenti violemment beaucoup plus
violemment moi qui est né ici j'ai
grandi ici
d'un coup je me retrouve privé tous ces
droits là et c'est à part tête de genre
il se manifeste comment il se met la
partie visible de cet iceberg d'horreur
c'est évidemment le port du voile
pourquoi le port du voile parce qu'une
fois que vous avez voilé et mis sous
couvercle la moitié de la population il
ne vous reste plus qu'à dominer l'autre
moitié et pardon messieurs mais
peut-être la moitié la plus faible
puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui en tout cas
chez les femmes chez le peuple iranien
que voilà la force elle est là et donc
une fois que vous avez mis la moitié
de côté que vous les priver de plein de
droits
il vous reste une moitié à dominer et
c'est quand même plus simple
donc ce port du voile en Iran il est
obligatoire dès l'âge de 6 ans
pourquoi 6 ans
alors parce qu'on considère que c'est
l'âge à partir duquel on peut provoquer
quelque chose chez l'homme imaginez-vous
un enfant de 6 ans et donc c'est ça un
peu qui va dicter toutes ces règles
c'est quand est-ce que ça pourrait créer
quelque chose
je n'ose même pas dire le mot mais
susciter un désir chez l'homme
mais c'est pas la seule discrimination
que subissent les femmes en Iran puisque
les jeunes filles peuvent être mariés à
partir de l'âge de 9 ans pour les hommes
je crois que c'est 15 ou 16 donc rien
que sur ce chiffre là déjà on est on n'a
pas le même chiffre pour les hommes et
les femmes
on l'a dit ce matin
pas le droit de faire de vélo pas le
droit de faire de moto
pas le droit de chanter pas le droit de
danser et ça ce sont des interdictions
qui s'appliquent uniquement aux femmes
pas le droit d'aller dans des stades
alors une autre règle intéressante c'est
que on n'a pas le droit de voyager en
dehors du pays à moins d'avoir
l'autorisation de son père et puis une
fois qu'on est marié l'autorisation de
son mari
on ne peut pas dormir seul à l'hôtel on
doit être accompagné de son père ou de
son mari ou de son frère enfin en tout
cas d'un homme
certaines professions ne peuvent être
exercées que par des hommes par exemple
une femme ne peut pas être juge pourquoi
parce qu'on considère qu'une femme a
trop d'émotions
une femme a trop d'émotions elle ne veut
pas juger de manière neutre
le viol sur conjoint n'existe pas
et pour qu'un viol soit reconnu il faut
4 témoins
sachant que le témoignage d'une femme
vaut la moitié de celui d'un homme
une femme ne peut pas demander le
divorce à moins que le mari le lui ai
donné le droit de le faire au moment où
ils se sont mariés
et elle héritera de la moitié de ce qui
reviendra à son frère
alors tout ça peut vous paraître un peu
enfin très lointain pour des raisons que
je comprends tout à fait mais je
voudrais vous l'approcher un tout petit
peu de vous
on n'a pas vécu les choses les plus
atroces de cette liste que je viens de
vous raconter mais
avec ma soeur qui assise là à côté de
Maud et que vous avez vu ce matin par
icima on a dû se rendre en Iran en 2008
comme je vous le disais parce que notre
Père qui n'y habitait pas qui était allé
là-bas pour quelques temps il a fait un
accident de voiture un accident de
voiture qui qui finira par être fatal et
donc on s'est précipité pour aller dans
ce pays qu'on connaissait très peu ou
quasiment pas
on est toutes les deux Franco iranienne
on arrive dans le pays notre
préoccupation principale c'est
évidemment de voir notre père mais au
bout d'un moment on se dit aussi qu'il
faudra qu'on sorte de ce pays à cette
époque là moi j'ai 28 ans je suis mariée
mon mari est français il me signe mon
autorisation de sortie du territoire
mais on a un peu oublié dans notre
précipitation que ma jeune sœur n'a que
17 ans et qu'elle n'est pas mariée
et que notre père est dans le coma et
que donc il est impossible d'obtenir une
autorisation de sortie de la part du
père et que n'ayant pas de Marie le mari
ne peut pas la lutigner non plus et ça a
été à partir de ce moment là des
semaines et des semaines d'en faire
absolu elle devait passer son bac cette
année-là et on a dû faire des mains des
pieds des mains et vous voulez rien
entendre ils nous disait bah il est dans
le coma fais-lui signer on lui disait
bah non il est dans le coma il peut par
définition pas signer mais vraiment on
se heurter à une inhumanité absolue
et puis à force d'y être allé je sais
même plus combien d'heures on a passé
dans ces dans ces bureaux en se disant
allez on y retourne aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'on trouvera sur quelqu'un
de plus simple on sait même dit
peut-être on va la faire épouser un
cousin qui va lui signer son
autorisation de sortie pour pouvoir la
sortir de là et on a fini par tomber sur
un homme un peu plus souple mais je vous
assure qu'on en a vu une cinquantaine
avant qui a dit bon si le directeur de
l'hôpital écrit comme quoi le père ne
peut pas signer l'autorisation de sortie
je voulais sortir et donc moi à l'époque
28 ans avocate ma mère qui était avec
nous
on ne servait à rien on pouvait pas
faire quoi que ce soit pour ma sœur
lors de ce même séjour on dormait à
l'hôtel donc il y avait mon mari qui
était là ma sœur et ma mère on pouvait
le faire puisqu'il y avait mon mari donc
on avait ma sœur et ma mère avait le
droit on avait une chambre communicante
ça avait été le deal avec l'hôtel pour
qu'ils nous s'autorise à être là et au
moment de payer c'est évidemment donc ma
mère qui se rend à la réception pour
régler pour tous et là le type ça
parlera aux Iraniens qui sont là il fait
comme ça ma mère comprend pas elle dit
quoi vous voulez pas que je vous paye
moi je prends pas l'argent des femmes
et donc
il lui dit donne à ton beau-fils
d'anaton gendre et donc là
ma mère qui était pas particulièrement
féministe
a eu un mouvement
qui fait que c'était la première fois
qu'on a
que j'ai vu ma mère sortir comme ça de
ses gonds et elle a dit quelque chose
qu'on dit tout le temps maintenant dans
cette révolution donc elle est c'était
une féministe avant l'heure et une
révolutionnaire avant là elle lui a dit
mais tu crois que tu sors d'où t'avais
pas une mère pour être là et voilà et tu
as pas une sœur et t'as pas une femme et
je crois que c'est ce jour-là que je me
suis dit un qu'en fait j'allais être
féministe jusque alors je voyais pas
trop à quoi ça servait en étant ici en
France et deux que je n'y retournerai
pas tant que ce serait comme ça
et je vous disais aussi que je voulais
vous rapprocher un petit peu plus que ça
comme réalisé je suis avocate en droit
international et je suis enfin arbitre
et je vous disais que certaines
professions sont interdites je pourrais
pas exercer mon activité d'arbitre
puisque c'est aussi une activité qui
nécessite de juger donc vous voyez si
j'avais pas eu la chance que ma famille
quitte ce pays aujourd'hui la profession
que j'exerce et que j'exerce avec
passion je ne pourrais pas l'exercer
il y a une chose importante à dire aussi
parce que Hermine a tout à fait raison
et à toutes ces soirées à tous mais
c'est une prise de risque énorme pour
ces jeunes on a eu même à une époque des
jeunes qui se jetaient des
duos des building parce que la police
démarre se débarquait au soirée il y a
eu des jeunes gens qui sont morts de ça
et si la brigade des mœurs croisent Adam
et une femme dans une voiture et qu'il
n'est pas le père ou le frère ou le mari
ils embarquent les deux ils peuvent
embarquer les deux donc s'ils sont assis
sur un banc ils sont dans la rue enfin
ils peuvent embarquer les deux ils
peuvent faire un test de virginité à la
femme et c'est coup de fouet pour les
deux
donc
c'est un peu ça la réalité de la
jeunesse quand on dit qu'ils ont rien à
perdre c'est vraiment ça et aujourd'hui
ça c'est des choses auxquelles on est
habitué depuis 43 ans c'est terrible à
dire mais tout ce que je viens de vous
dire n'a rien d'inhabituel ce qui est
plus inhabituel c'est ce qui se passe là
depuis quelques mois
ou les Gardiens de la Révolution vont
dans les manifestations choisissent les
plus belles je sais pas si vous avez vu
les filles photos de nos victimes ils
choisissent les plus belles les emmène
en prison il les viole impunément
et puis dans les manifestations il les
vise avec leurs armes ils visent les
yeux et ils vivent levage en des femmes
donc c'est ça aussi être une femme
aujourd'hui on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup chiappach et je
pense qu'en effet ton témoignage est
édifiant et très important parce que
pour beaucoup de personnes en France je
ne citerai personne le combat des
Iraniens a été vu comme un combat
antivol et Armin la souligné également
ce ne sont pas des militantes antivol et
ce sont vraiment des combattantes pour
la liberté je pense que c'est très
important de le souligner
on voit que depuis 4 mois et demi ce
combat continue il y a quelques années
il y avait eu l'épisode des mercredi
blanc
ça n'avait pas vraiment
abouti à quelque chose mais aujourd'hui
on semble s'apercevoir que rien ne va
décourager la jeunesse iranienne qui
descend dans la rue au péril de sa vie
de jour en jour il y a la répression
mais pour autant ils sont encore plus
nombreux le lendemain
azadé quel est ton regard sur cette
révolution
bonjour merci à tout le monde merci à
vous à deux organisateurs de cette
journée je remercie particulièrement
moderne pour son accueil je remercie les
élus j'ai remarqué tous les personnes
qui sont présents les intervenants et
merci Aurélie je sais que l'organisation
toujours ce n'est pas une tâche facile
mais tu l'as réussi bravo
et
je suis particulièrement contente de de
parler après hormis parce que tout ce
qu'il a dit en quelque sorte c'est ce
que je voulais dire mais d'un point de
vue de philosophique mais je suis
vraiment tellement heureuse parce que
quand j'étais en train de préparer ce
texte en fait ce que j'écris j'ai
réfléchi de quel point de vue par quel
angle d'attaque je peux je peux parler
de l'Iran et tout ce qui se passe
actuellement parce que il y a tellement
de choses à parler que parfois on dit ok
de quoi puis-je parler et j'ai trouvé un
angle d'attaque on va y arriver mais
vraiment
les propos de Armin je pense que
clarifie et rendre la compréhension de
de mon texte très aisé merci beaucoup
pour cette intervention c'était un
hasard mais c'était voilà c'était très
bien mais avant de commencer en fait je
voudrais vous faire
je ne suis pas comme mes collègues ici
présents j'ai un texte donc en tant
qu'académique voilà je vais regarder mon
texte oui m'excuser mais je voudrais
aussi vous faire un aveu et que malgré
mal mon appartement
au monde iranien je ne suis pas une
érudite des études iraniennes quand vous
avez pu voir je viens
d'amandes des études recturnes mais je
sais en fait de mettre ma connaissance
au point de vue philosophique pour
interpréter ce qui se passe en Iran
et par là je voudrais vous dire que mon
appartenance à la fois généalogique et
historique à son monde m'oblige à en
payer les charges parce que appartenir
développe une obligation ça c'est un
cœur qui disait cela m'invitons qu'à
réfléchir en tant que philosophe et à
dire ce que la philosophie peut proposer
face à la situation iranienne face à
tondeuse stigmates laissées par le mal
tout ce qui sont en train de nous dire
c'est le mal c'est rien d'autre
face aux dernières heures du temps
ténébreux de ce pays
qui a accueilli les premières crues de
mon existante et sur beaucoup d'entre
nous ici présents
donc si d'un côté une telle appartenance
appelle sans cesse l'existence d'un
réseau bien complexe ce que Armin vient
de dire champagne
ou ses acteurs tentent harmoniser le
désastre et le roi
la détresse et la solidarité la
tristesse et la gaieté pourtant creuse
et vider de toutes et sensuelle de notre
côté la philosophie dénonce le cynisme
de ce réseau consistant à concilier le
contraire ce réseau est une forme
d'incohérence continue et comme dirait
quel plus grandes violence qu'un
cohérence donc nous sommes dans
incohérence totale mais la philosophie
n'est pas seule à nous offrir des
repères utiles pour comprendre le
soulèvement iranien et le rôle
d'individu iranien situé au cœur de tout
cela Armin parlait de films de cette
représentation imagée remarquable qui
qui a expliqué la situation en Europe
pour tout le monde
l'exposition qu'on convient de voir ici
nous donne aussi quelques repères elle
est très riche elle nous donnait accès à
l'espace de notre mémoire collective
voire personnelle et aussi aux
témoignages des événements récents en
Iran ces photos expriment cette réalité
selon laquelle tout en étant dans un
monde libre
nous sommes tous investis et secoués par
le désir de la liberté des Iraniens et
leurs bravures ces photos sont une
modalité d'expression par excellence qui
convergent dans l'actualité des
événements en cours en Europe et
l'exprime une sorte d'alliance entre
l'individu iranien et son destin qui est
en jeu et les relie à nous tous
ces photos montrent aussi que le destin
de l'Iran ou plutôt le suicide de son
destin et en train de s'emparer de
chacun de nous en nous projetant en
dehors du champ de nos vies habituelles
il y a quelques mois je pense que aucun
d'entre nous pouvait s'imaginer de se
retrouver ici en train de parler de ce
sujet là ensemble on se connaissait même
pas en quelque sorte donc elles sont
propres de la déconstruction et la
reconfiguration de la représente ses
photos de la reconfiguration les
représenter de la représentation imagée
de l'Iran et des Iraniens une des photos
de ami de Rosemonde dont j'ai apprécie
particulièrement son travail il a ici
j'ai eu l'occasion aussi à lui dire
parce que son travail me donne
particulièrement en fait ça me donne
tout le temps tout le temps des à penser
en quelque sorte en était moi la photo
en fait c'est ici
je parle de cette femme qui en prend
l'oeuvre magistrale de Jeanne Delacroix
cette photo en elle seule comprend tout
le symbolisme révolutionnaire véhicule
le désir de la liberté et appelle à la
merveillement la femme libre le peuple
ou la violence l'héroïsme
révolutionnaire le patriotisme la mère
patrie rien n'y fait défaut elle ne se
déroule pas face à son rendez-vous avec
l'histoire c'est une photo pleinement
dans le cours de l'histoire
mais pas seulement ces photos dans leur
ensemble suscitent un autre symbolisme
celui de l'espérance et c'est là que je
place en fait tout le discours de
l'espérance calle et car elle exige la
réalisation de la liberté comme un
ultime point d'aboutissement de quelle
espérance par lèche je m'explique en
m'appuyant sur les travaux remarquables
de d'une philosophe française que
vraiment j'apprécie beaucoup son travail
de plus en plus court une polochon
ensuite dans un second temps je vais
aborder quelques écueils quand même
parce que en tant que iranien je pense
que il est nécessaire que nous regardons
la situation en face qu'on puisse faire
le bilan de tout ce qui se passe pas le
bilan mais quelques conseils puissent
expliquer ce qui se passe donc je vais
aborder quelques écueils rencontrées sur
ce parcours vers l'avènement de la
liberté
alors qu'est-ce que l'espérance
se redit Corinne polluchon et que
l'espérance et le désespoir surmontait
la certitude quand dépit de déception et
des rendez-vous manqués des retards et
de quelques régressions quelque chose se
passe qui va réorienter le cours des
choses et générer un progrès quand je
lis ça je comprends mieux cette phrase
cette fois c'est différent on a tous
entendu
cette fois c'est différent car les
Iraniens ne font que rejeter la
sélection déguisée des Brahim raïti en
élection et son choix par le guide
suprême Armin a très bien expliqué ce
processus comment ça se passe
ce qui n'était pas le cas pour les mêmes
types d'élections
où je dis encore sélection pendant la
période de réformes ou l'horizon datant
des Iraniens a été nourri par l'espoir
c'est-à-dire cette attente qui souhaite
l'arrivée d'un jour inconnue ou la
liberté sera lisera enfin
l'appareil la période de réformes et
même le long est sombre et spectacle des
négociations sur le Leclerc
réconforter les Iraniens en leur donnant
de l'espoir
mais en réalité
ils étaient dans une forme de nihilisme
toute cette histoire ce corps me disait
oui c'est la faute des mots là oui tout
ça il y en a certains qui effectivement
ils étaient ils étaient cohérent ils
connaissaient que ou peut-être il savait
qu'ils sont dans cette forme donnée
nourrit par l'espoir ce qui les privé de
la liberté de douter et qui les
empêchaient de mettre un terme au mal
qui les envahissaient parler d'espoir
signifie donc que nous formons nous
formons le vœu que quelque chose arrive
cet espoir au fond c'est un désespoir
qui s'ignore
l'espoir entrave toute initiative toute
pensée critique j'insiste sur ce terme
et je reviendrai souvent dans dans mon
dans mes propos et c'est pour cela que
la République islamique a essayé entre
autres de donner l'espoir aux Iraniens à
travers des différentes périodes
dans l'air dans leur discussions
courante les Iraniens disent entre eux
ah que la République islamique a gagné
du temps avec les réformes autrement dit
la République islamique a fait entrer
les Iraniens dans une forme de nihilisme
nourrit par l'espoir quand j'étais en
train de écrire ses propos j'ai réalisé
que le nom du dernier gouvernement
réformateur en Europe justement le
gouverneur le gouvernement de l'espoir
et de stratégies de la tête à bilan
c'était le nom qui portait triste au
hasard ou pas je vous laisse juge par
conséquent quand on dit que cette fois
est différent
nous disons clairement que les Iraniens
n'en veulent plus de se désespoir
ignoré car l'espérance a pris dessous de
la détresse et devenue d'ours déjà un
chemin une méthode l'espérance d'une se
regarde ton Bachelard appelle le sens de
problème et nous fait sortir des idées
est-ce que le rosé nous permet
d'apprendre chaque jour de s'améliorer
et de trouver des nouvelles méthodes
pour avancer si le temps de l'espérance
est arrivé si cette fois c'est différent
c'est parce que la sélection de réussie
comme l'incarnation de tous les
de tous les désastres soumis par les
Iraniens restent le point culminant de
désespoir et d'angoisse
l'espoir l'espérance nous dit qu'aucune
réponse toute faite n'existe face aux
angoisses politiques voire
existentielles
face au désespoir
et je vais aller un petit peu vite et
pour
jouer arriver vers quelques écoles quand
même je vais pas
vous lire tout ce que j'ai écrit mais
sur ce chemin de
l'espérance quand même on sait qu'il
faut travailler c'est un chemin qui
nécessite une méthode un travail une
réflexion permanente et qu'il faut
s'adapter il faut avoir la raison
critique donc il y a comme tout combat
il y a quelques écueils que je vous
énumère comme suit 1 cela fait 4
décennie que la République islamique
impose l'idéologie islamiste et par tous
les moyens oppose une certaine croyance
titre religieuse à toute idéale
cosmopolitique le Swift de la démocratie
nous perçoit que la fin de l'idéologie
islamiste ne laissera pas de place
récupérable par une autre forme
idéologique
néanmoins le vide laissait par la fin de
l'idéologie et que voilà pardon je dois
prendre mon téléphone mon texte
et donc sous vite doit être traversé
avec beaucoup de convictions et
considération car Sopal car sans ce
passage aucune société ethnique dans un
héron de demain qu'on espère
démocratique ne serait possible et c'est
pour cela qu'il faut déclencher tout
processus qui permettent la mise en
oeuvre de l'esprit critique
aujourd'hui le souhait de le numéro 2 le
souhait de l'opposition iranienne dans
toute sa pluralité et l'installation de
la démocratie on a tous d'accord et
c'est dans l'absence de fondement et
d'institution et démocratique que ce
soit existe donc la manque d'une
certaine expérience démocratique
considérée comme un comme une véritable
expérience comme démocratique considérée
comme une véritable expérience
démocratique iranienne et l'absence fait
partie politique qui crée un flux un
vague dépourvu de l'expérience d'une
réalité démocratique concrète propre à
l'Iran il reste difficile pour les
Iraniens de modifier leur perception de
l'organisation politique à venir dans
leur pays
il faut aussi souligner l'importance
c'est le numéro 3 l'importance du
comportement social politique et
culturelle les Iraniens dans ce contexte
les Iraniens sont imprégnés de la
mémoire traumatique du passé ce qui le
conduit souvent vers une connaissance
erronée du monde de leur pays et de même
sol une connaissance précise serait
capable d'inciter les Iraniens à
modifier le rapport au pouvoir leur
perception au monde et au foot du monde
et de futurs de leur pays et à les
engager dans la voie de construction des
institutions justes
et
j'avançais juste je vous ajoute un autre
point qui repose sur l'extrême violence
parce que hormis justement il en a parlé
aussi sur l'extrême violence langagière
virtuel entre les différentes
protagonistes qui va avec brutalité à
l'encontre de toute forme de civilité
numérique on qualifie souvent facilement
les gens voilà tes lobbistes tes soucis
tes sola voilà le parole le problème des
violences numériques version
révolutionnaire et que les personnes en
sortiront extrêmement détérioré ces
individus bruit et parasites notre
imagination sociale et politique
pourtant indispensable pour la
reconstruction de l'avenir dans notre
pays un avenir qui est en train
d'investir le présent d'un grand pas
restons prudent parce que il se pourrait
qu'on connaît pas le temps pour réparer
nos incivilités
quelques constats l'ennemi des Iraniens
reste inchangé les Iraniens sont certes
engloutis dans le trajet d'une vie
encadre encadrée imposée par le démon de
tout totalitarisme mais ils savent que
toute tragédie comme ils savent que
comme toute tragédie le destin de
Monique sera vaincu grâce à la sagesse
c'est quoi c'est à dire grâce à l'usage
de la raison voilà merci
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à Z et une touche
d'espoir ça fait du bien
cependant il y a une question que tout
le monde se pose et si tout se passe
bien pour le peuple iranien le régime
tombe mais quelle est la suite
Manelli comment est-ce que voilà comment
est-ce que ton visage la suite est-ce
qu'il y a des gens au sein de la
diaspora qui sont capables de voilà de
d'apporter leur support à l'Iran pour
pour prendre la suite du régime actuel
le nom de resa palavie circulait un peu
dans la presse internationale sur les
réseaux sociaux quel est ton point de
vue aujourd'hui
alors évidemment je vais vous parler de
quelle suite qu'est-ce qu'on peut
espérer envisager vouloir de cette
révolution
vous l'avez bien rappelé c'était écrit
tu l'as bien rappelé à cette fois-ci
c'est la bonne c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
entre nous on est passé partout le
processus qui a expliqué à mine pour en
arriver là et aujourd'hui on voit dans
cette révolution des signes des atouts
des caractéristiques qui en font une
révolution vraiment avant garde avant
garde pour quelle raison et la démarrer
par les femmes le combat qui a expliqué
très justement chapanac elle a démarré
par les femmes pour expliquer au monde
qu'on était dans un aparté de genre qui
n'a jamais été qualifié dans le monde de
crime alors que l'apartheid de race est
aujourd'hui complètement qualifiée de
crime donc notre combat à tous et à
toutes c'est de reconnaître que cet
aparté de genre est un crime contre
l'humanité cette solution à impliquer
dès le début trois générations
différentes la génération meurtrie la
génération
traumatisée dans un traumatisme
collectif dont fait partie ma mère qui
est là qui a qui qui a fait cette
révolution qui lui a été volé qui a vécu
une guerre de 8 ans avec 2 millions de
morts et qui ne se sentait pas capable
de s'en relever elle a impliqué la
génération qui est ma génération celle
qui a cru en les réformes qui étaient
dans les rues par millions pour essayer
d'améliorer le système à éviter que de
sang du sang se verse dans les rues et
la génération de il y a cette génération
qui finalement a beaucoup plus de
sagesse que nos deux autres générations
pour comprendre qu'on ne peut plus jouer
dans le même terrain et essayer à la
marge de répondre au système il faut un
moment donné un système obsolète
j'emploie désolé ce mot qui est très
brut et très cru de pourri mais parce
que je n'en trouve pas d'autre une
plante qui est pourrie à la racine et
qui qui qu'on ne peut plus sauver on ne
peut plus sauver il faut sortir de ce
terrain de jeu donc cette génération l'a
très bien compris et il y a vraiment un
petit un système qui se tisse entre ces
trois générations qui ont fait une
révolution vraiment très intéressante
et il faut comprendre que le centre de
gravité de cette révolution porte sur
quelque chose qui est complètement
universel reconnu qui n'est pas
iranienne elle est dans un rejet d'une
idéologie islamique d'une idéologie j'en
reviens je viendrai sur ça après
antioxydant et a fait voir au monde
entier que cette idéologie n'est qu'une
façade et n'a pu de racines en fait n'a
plus de racine dans une société qui l'a
portée qui était censée la porter depuis
longtemps on a souvent reproché pour
pour répondre à ta question au début on
a souvent reproché à ce mouvement de
manquer de leadership
pour avoir travaillé longtemps sur des
systèmes les systèmes social etc moi j'y
voyais au contraire un atout parce que
évidemment venant d'un pays libre comme
ici ou des partis politiques existent ou
des voix émergent ou des personnalités
peuvent porter la voix d'un certain une
certaine partie de la population
évidemment on pourrait se dire que quand
il y a pas de leadership ça va tomber à
l'eau à un moment donné ça va s'arrêter
mais l'intérêt de ce mouvement était au
contraire de manquer au départ de
leadership et d'être complètement
horizontal et décentralisée dans un pays
qui a vécu 43 ans de répression féroce
de toute idée je parle même pas de parti
politique ou de de d'activistes
politiques toute idée qui peuvent
émerger dans votre tête à partir du
moment où ça s'exprime et réprimer donc
à partir de ce moment là façonner
j'allais dire un peu de de ce qui existe
soit on reste face à ce né soit on se
dit que on va avancer sans leadership et
au contraire la force de ça c'est que on
ne se laissera pas berner comme on l'a
on l'a été en 709 par des personnalités
qui peuvent émerger et prendre un peu le
pouvoir dans leurs mains je viendrai sur
la question de réseau par la vie je
pense que ça vous intéresse donc ça
c'est un peu les atouts de cette
révolution et qui ont été hyper
intéressantes à regarder et avoir dans
la durée parce que 5 mois c'est pas rien
5 mois de répression
c'est du 24 heures sur 24 en Iran donc
c'est c'est assez impactant
donc ce qui me conduit vers la réussite
que je vois dès aujourd'hui en fait dans
cette révolution qu'est-ce que ça a
apporté aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que ça
peut apporter demain
ce que ça a apporté
je qualifie souvent le régime islamique
d'un système qui tient sur un trépied je
veux pas dire trois piliers parce que ça
les glorifie un peu un très Piet qui
était assez stable ce trépied était
d'une part l'idéologie qui était de deux
ordres l'idéologie islamique et
l'idéologie antioxydants
deuxièmement c'était la terreur faire
régner la terreur et troisièmement
c'était l'économie parce que évidemment
vous savez tous un pays riche c'est un
pays c'est un système économique ouvert
vers l'extérieur ce n'est absolument pas
le la Corée du Nord qui est dans une
espèce d'autosuffisance l'Iran malgré
les sanctions qui ont pesé sur l'Iran
n'a jamais pu être isolée et ne sait ne
s'est jamais isolé en fait
sont complètement entrés dans la
contestation parce que justement elle
avait les caractéristiques que
j'expliquais j'expliquais avant ensuite
sur le plan de la terreur ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la terreur c'est
pas juste le risque de se prendre une
balle dans la tête la terreur des
Iraniens c'est que l'Iran soit séparé
qu'il y ait des mouvements séparatifs la
terreur des Iraniens c'est quoi après la
terreur des Iraniens c'est de revivre ce
qu'on a vécu en 79 donc on est pendant
43 ans ce régime nous a séparé tous les
Iraniens de la diaspora en Iran etc il
nous a séparé en s'appuyant sur nos
peurs et pour la première fois de
l'histoire et je pense que ça c'est un
des grands apports de cette de cette
révolution c'est que il y a eu un
mouvement de réunion d'unification entre
tous les Iraniens de tout bord la peur
de des séparatistes la peur de l'après
la peur de on a tous laissé tomber parce
que les valeurs pour lesquelles on se
bat
sont tellement dans notre ordre sont
tellement grands que ces peurs n'ont
plus de signification et ça ça a été
vraiment l'échec du régime qu'on a très
bien vu aujourd'hui et ensuite
économique je pense que il y a revenir
dessus donc je vais pas trop m'attarder
parce que je veux qu'il est qu'il est le
temps de pas reçu suffisante mais
aujourd'hui juste pour vous dire que ce
système c'est un système qui en faillite
économique tous les voyants tous les
indicateurs sont rouges et il n'y a rien
qui moi je dis souvent c'est l'économie
tient encore mais ne tient plus c'est
vraiment on est du jour au lendemain
économiquement l'Iran pourrait pourrait
faillir et pour être tomber ils sortent
eux-mêmes massivement je vous invite si
vous n'avez pas déjà fait dans Paris
Match il y a un article très très bien
documenté là-dessus ils sont en train de
de piller l'Iran et de sortir des
lingots d'or et des milliards et des
milliards de dollars et ça c'est un
signe c'est-à-dire que leur manque de
confiance en
ça pourrait ça pourrait donner cette
révolution pour eux
et très et très remarqué les grèves
continuent après on est toujours dans un
système de débrouillardisme évidemment
le droit de grève comme ici n'existe pas
donc ça se fait par petits morceaux on
essaye d'éviter qu'on soit réprimé etc
mais les grèves existent des blocages et
des sabotages existent je vous donne
un petit exemple
le on a commencé à avoir une pénurie de
gaz dans tous les rangs et le moyen très
judicieux qu'on trouvait la population
pour utiliser sa contre le système ça a
été dans les villes les plus
industrielles d'augmenter leur
consommation de gaz de foyer pour faire
que les industries ne puissent plus
fonctionner et ça a marché c'est à dire
que voilà le message que j'avoue passait
c'est que c'est très évolution est une
réussite jusqu'ici parce qu'elle est
ingénieuse parce qu'elle est
avant-gardiste parce que
je pense qu'il y a va vous l'expliquer
il y a vraiment
on change nos méthodes par rapport à ce
qu'on a en face par rapport à
l'arrestation qu'on a en face et et les
jeunes savent très très bien faire ça
qu'est-ce que ça pourrait donner après
il y a aussi l'aspect géopolitique qui
est très important inconsidéré c'est
cette révolution en Iran n'est pas
iranienne c'est une révolution au
Moyen-Orient c'est une révolution pour
le monde
les gens politiques elle est de
plusieurs ordres il y a il y a vraiment
une espèce de je pense que Armin je
parle souvent de ça cet axe réussi Shin
Iran qui s'est dessiné ces dernières
années et qui
c'est s'appuyer un peu sur ce sur cette
fratrie pour essayer de contrer
l'Occident bah aujourd'hui on voit
qu'elle est pas si
si forte que ça on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que il n'y a pas cette
espèce de pacte qu'on a qu'on a toujours
imaginé entre ces trois puissances parce
que économiquement la Chine commence à
lâcher l'Iran parce que sur le dossier
nucléaire ni la Russie ni l'Iran n'ont
jamais soutenu l'Iran
la Russie et la Chine et donc on voit
bien qu'en fait cette espèce de de
j'allais dire géopolitique qu'on
imaginait n'existe plus donc même sur
l'aspect géopolitique
le fait que l'Iran tombe peut avoir une
répercussion évidemment sur sur nos
cutter j'allais dire russe d'abord parce
que la Chine un peu plus moins
impactante pour nous et puis dans le
Moyen-Orient dans le Moyen-Orient par
rapport au droit des femmes évidemment
ne sera bien on serait grandit je pense
de de cette révolution là et évidemment
un effet domino qui pourrait impacter
toute la région et qui pourrait vraiment
porter un espoir non seulement pour le
Moyen-Orient mais pour
le monde entier en fait par rapport à
cette idéologie islamique qu'ils ont
porté et qu'ils ont promis pendant des
années je pense notamment à la Syrie je
pense Libye je pense au Yémen tous ces
pays-là s'il y avait pas l'hégémonie
iranienne
n'aurait pas le sort qu'ils avaient
aujourd'hui et nous activer je pense
qu'on a tous tous et toutes ça en tête
on ne se bat pas que pour nous-même et
ça c'est un des grands atouts et je
pense que moi c'est vraiment sur ça que
porte l'espoir elle est universelle et
humaniste
par rapport à ta question par rapport à
ce qu'il y a un leadership qui émerge je
pense qu'on est tous dans le diaspora
uni sur cette idée que le leadership qui
va émerger de ce mouvement devra venir
de l'intérieur et on a suffisamment de
personnes on a suffisamment d'idées on a
suffisamment de penseurs pour penser
l'Iran d'après le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont où ils sont dans
les prisons c'est le seul pays où on
appelle nos prisons des universités
toutes ces personnes sont en prison et
nous notre rôle si on a un rôle à jouer
ici et le rôle de quelqu'un comme les
autres par la vie évidemment c'est de
gérer cette phase de transition et je
j'insiste bien sur le mot gérer ce n'est
pas guidé mais c'est de gérer cette
phase de transition jusqu'à ce qu'on
remette au peuple ce droit d'aller voter
d'aller se vivre au niveau politique
d'exercer ces libertés et de et de
choisir pour eux-mêmes donc qu'il y ait
une entité symbolique évidemment parce
qu'à un moment les symboles sont
importants mais je pense que sont plus
importantes pour j'allais dire vous en
tant que représente du MoDem et et parce
que vous avez je pense que
le cerveau humain
elle se problématique qu'il a besoin de
combler le néant quand on est face à
néant qu'on sait pas ce que ce qu'il y a
après on a du mal à se projeter et donc
d'avoir des symboles d'avoir des
personnalités qui portent cette voie
pour arriver à avoir quelqu'un en face
et et faire abstraction de de ce qui
n'est pas encore construit évidemment ça
son rôle à jouer moi personnellement
mais ça c'est vraiment
j'allais dire un enjeu personnel
je fais toute confiance à cette à nos a
par la vie pour gérer cette phase de
transition mais évidemment on a aussi
des gens qui n'ont pas cette vision et
ils font aussi partie de ce système
révolutionnaire il faut les entendre il
faut les reconnaître mais que je sache
aucun aucun
président aucun porte-parole n'a jamais
été validé par 100% de la population il
y a un moment donné il faut avancer il
faut faire un pas il faut choisir et il
faut
ne pas avoir peur aussi de changer de
chemin en fait si demain le pack ne pas
respecté c'est demain le mandat n'est
pas respecté ce n'est qu'un mandat en
fait pas un pacte d'ailleurs je me
reprends c'est un mandat qui est donné
et donc rien ne nous empêche demain de
de changer de voix après ça c'est
vraiment un avis personnel que je fasse
je le souligne c'est pas forcément voilà
je parle pas au nom de tout le monde
donc voilà mon message c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir après que
meilleur en fait que meilleur
c'est pas un chemin qui va aboutir en
quelques mois on sait on sait à quoi ça
tendre on est très lucide je pense que
souvent on est on est quand on parle de
l'humanisme quand on parle de
l'universalisme on nous traite
d'idéalises ou d'utopique
moi je me revendique très pragmatique et
je pense que si on avait traité des
résistants
au moment de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
l'idéaliste d'utopique ça n'aurait pas
été juste parce qu'on n'en serait pas là
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci beaucoup ma Nelly
la presse les médias relaient qu'il se
passe en Iran on a la chance d'avoir
aujourd'hui il y a tu es un activiste
iranien tu vas nous raconter ce qui se
passe là-bas tu vas également nous
expliquer de quoi l'Iran aurait besoin
pour mener à bien cette révolution on
sait que le peuple iranien demande un
plus d'engagement de la part de la
communauté internationale certains pays
se sont engagés un peu plus que la
France aujourd'hui et dans un deuxième
temps Armin si la France était amenée à
s'engager un peu plus j'ai entendu dans
une interview récente que vous
considériez que le climat entre la
France et l'Iran aujourd'hui n'amenait
pas à sourire on a vu les menaces et
le fait que la France était ciblée à la
suite des caricatures des mots là dans
Charlie Hebdo on a parlé de la
dissuasion nucléaire beaucoup de sujets
rentrent en compte est-ce que le climat
entre la France et l'Iran pourrait se
refroidir encore plus si jamais la
France venait à s'engager un peu plus
auprès de l'Iran qui vous donnerai la
parole dans un deuxième temps si vous
voulez bien il y a Manelli je te laisse
traduire
[Musique]
politique avant d'être en activiste
social je suis d'abord un combattant et
je me sens aujourd'hui même ici étant la
rue et combattre
je vais diviser ma disco en deux parties
la première c'est de vous expliquer ce
qui se passe sur le terrain c'est ça qui
est très important
la voix du peuple est un deuxième partie
ce qui est ce que peut être et doit être
le rôle et la responsabilité de
l'Occident et de la France en
particulier de l'Europe
cela fait 5 mois que la les
contestations ont commencé en Iran et il
s'agit ce que vous devez comprendre ce
qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas de
contestations juste pour le foulard ou
juste pour amener des améliorations de
la loi ou même de la de la Constitution
on est bel et bien j'insiste dans une
révolution
on cherche à instaurer un
système politique qui soit complètement
ouvert et complètement
multi-partite avec l'ensemble des idées
qui puissent s'exprimer
va doucement
un autre révolution est avant tout une
guerre nous sommes dans une guerre où
dans un camp il y a nous les mains vides
aux puces on a des cailloux dans les
mains et en face de nous on a un régime
qui a toute l'arsenal militaire pour
nous combattre
qui
a une répression qui varie à la forme de
la répression varie d'une ville à
l'autre et une région à l'autre mot
touchant
dans les villes comme ça et dans on est
face à un véritablement une politique de
génocide là où a Téhéran on est dans des
répressions des des gaz lacrymogènes et
des tiers sur les gens à balle pourtant
au Kurdistan et le restant donc la ville
de zahidan
la ville de Zaidan le régime utilise des
artillerie lourdes et semi-lourdes
contre la population donc c'est vraiment
une répression systémique contre contre
le peuple
utilise des artillies comme Douchka
alors le nom en français je l'ai cherché
c'est un
dshk qui est une artillerie lourde de
gros calibre qui sont utilisés en guerre
contre les tanks mais eux ils utilisent
pour tirer sur les personnes
j'ai vu un garçon de 12 ans qui a reçu
trois balles dans son corps
et beaucoup d'autres exemples
il utilise tout ce qu'il peut alors
peut-être pas l'artillerie lourde mais
en tout cas des des balles qui
renferment beaucoup de billes il y a
aussi kalachnikov qui a été utilisé à
Téhéran donc tout ce qui peut tout ce
qu'il faut trouver un peu dans son
arsenal plus légère entre guillemets
mais qui utilise contre les manifestants
à côté de ça il y a un désastre qui se
passe dans les prisons violent
systématisé sur femme homme et enfant
et désormais répertorié et on a et dans
les prisons très très pratiqués dans les
prisons comme torture
répertoriés dans les et donc
d'emprisonnement dans les prisons de
l'Iran
sont toujours en cours on a eu ceux qui
ont été médiatisés mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres qui ne sont pas
médiatisés dont on n'a pas connaissance
médiatiquement à ce jour
on fait face je vais vous donner un
exemple très
précisations qu'on avait il y avait
quelques personnes qui ont été
blessés par des balles
une femme médecin de manière
indépendante à son
commence à aider ses blessés
le régime prend connaissance et kidnappe
ce médecin
on n'avait pas de nouvelles de cette
dame jusqu'à ce que plus quelques jours
plus tard on trouve son corps sans vie
encore où les membres étaient cassés les
le nez cassé la figure des figurés et
les yeux sortis de leur orbite
j'espère que vous avez compris à quoi on
fait face
[Musique]
chaque jour en Iran nous on est face à
des crimes contre l'humanité un génocide
contre notre peuple
donc quiconque a dit que non notre
réclamation c'est d'avoir des réformes
ou d'avoir le même système un peu
amélioré n'est que alors il n'a pas
trouvé de mots polis pour le dire mais
c'est moi je pourrais dire c'est
vraiment des mensonges et du n'importe
quoi
on sait dans le monde entier que les
étudiants ont toujours eu un rôle très
important dans les dans les révolutions
et dans les contestations politiques
Jean-Marc battes
les étudiants ont fait des
manifestations dans les universités
parce que quand ils sont dans les
universités ils ont ils peuvent pas
prétendre qu'ils sont dans la rue pour
contester et ils n'ont pas cette espèce
de légitimité normalement à les réprimer
et pourtant on a eu sur ces 5 mois des
centaines de cas d'empoisonnements
groupés des des étudiants dans les
universités
mais on reste debout
la chose la plus importante de la plus
dure à laquelle on fait face c'est le
boycotte médiatique aujourd'hui
tous les réseaux sociaux sont filtrés
ont été tellement diminuées rétrécie
même les VPN ne marchent plus
connecter difficilement avec des
vipiennes tout ce qu'on fait on peut
faire passer ces quelques mots c'est
quelques phrases les tout ce qui est
photo vidéo a beaucoup de mal à passer
et sachez que ça ne signifie pas quand
on reçoit pas d'image que la
contestation diminue c'est juste qu'on
en est moins informé
la manière dont on manifeste et on fait
la révolution en Iran dit cher de ce que
vous auriez pu connaître d'une
révolution classique parce que on a
cette répression faire sans face
en fait on essaie d'être astucieux on se
met à jour face à une répression de qui
se porte sur des manifestations
centralisées nous on va choisir d'être
décentralisé d'être dans des dans des
manifestations de mobilisations de
quartier par quartier pour essayer de
disperser aussi les forces de l'ordre
tellement bien
échec d'Algérien
par exemple le terrain il pourrait y
avoir des des
mobilisations
assez massive mais qui sont répartis sur
200 points sur la sur la carte
en dehors du fait qu'on n'arrive pas à
envoyer les les images
en fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on a le
problème qu'on a c'est aussi qu'on ne
peut pas apprendre les images quelqu'un
qui a qui a un téléphone portable dans
sa main
de de
l'appareil photo j'ai même un téléphone
portable qui filme c'est ce que ça peut
être film Madrid
[Applaudissements]
qui filmait de sa voiture les
manifestations
[Musique]
de sa vie
de cas comme celui-là où les gens ont
filmé sans savoir les dernières instants
de leur vie parce qu'il voulait
témoigner de ce de ce qui se passe
donc vous comprenez que si les
informations et de moins en moins
d'informations qui sont de l'Iran
pourquoi
pourquoi on entend moi parler c'est
parce qu'il se passe rien c'est qu'on ne
peut pas voir
il peut en vrai sur la deuxième partie
et quelle est l'attente du peuple
iranien de la France et de l'Europe
la République islamique c'est comme un
pieuvre
qui a plusieurs bras à l'intérieur de
l'Iran et plusieurs à l'extérieur de
Lyon
on sait comment couper ses bras qui sont
à l'intérieur et on a la force
suffisante et le et l'écran pour le
faire
on sera là on le fera
à l'extérieur de l'Iran nous demande pas
à ce que quelqu'un fasse la révolution
pour nous on demande à ce que les pays
extérieurs soient à nos côtés
les bras de ce régime islamique à
l'extérieur c'est les bras qui qui le
nourrissent économiquement qui lui donne
des armes et qui
et qui font la propagande pour ce régime
on ne peut pas continuer à dire qu'on
est en même temps noir et en même temps
blanc à un moment donné il va falloir
choisir son camp
la France et l'Europe un moment donné
doit se décider ou bien on reste au côté
de la Révolution République islamique à
nourrir ses bras ou alors on se met au
côté du peuple
je répète encore ce n'est pas la ce ne
sont pas des contestations mais c'est
bien une révolution si c'était des
contestations on aurait abandonné ça
fait cinq mois que ça dure c'est bien
une révolution et ce n'est pas une
révolution pour nous c'est une
révolution pour la région et pour le
monde entier
on a parfois oublié des choses
oublier
morte
qui se tient à nos côtés et qui continue
à collaborer avec le régime islamique
il faut même pas penser à quelle option
on aura si la que vous aurez si le
régime reste parce que soyez sûr que le
régime va
partira pas c'est nous qui le mettrons
dehors
[Applaudissements]
l'autre fan va ça te poser une inconnue
s'il vous plaît arrêtez de jouer au
centre le message qui va vous faire
passer c'est que il faut choisir son
camp dès aujourd'hui dès maintenant
parce que plus le temps passe plus le
régime islamique va étendre ses menaces
jusqu'à arriver chez vous dans vos
maisons en France c'est et on le voit
bien ces derniers ces dernières semaines
et il est temps de choisir dès
aujourd'hui son camp et on s'en
souviendra il a terminé ça
et première étape pour ça pour aider le
peuple et se tenir à ses côtés c'est de
placer les Gardiens de la révolution
donc hier je sais comme organisation
terroriste il y a dit qu'il remarque en
Europe les pays se regardent les uns les
autres l'Allemagne regarde la France la
France regarde l'Allemagne et puis
personne n'ose prendre le premier pas
mais il est important désormais d'être
leader nous on le paye en Iran au prix
de notre sang
n'attendez pas pour le payer au prix
politique fort parce que le régime
islamique c'est réprimé sa réprimé
moment d'horre de ses frontières
que le peuple iranien comme il a dit
n'oubliera pas et que demain dans un
état démocratique on saura répondre à
tous ceux qui se sont tenus à côté à
côté de nous et qui nous ont soutenu
dans cette révolution
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la traduction c'est une parfaite
transition avec le climat français
Armin je vous laisse la parole
oui
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
et cette très très clair cette vague
d'espoir que tu transmets
c'est très très difficile du coup pour
moi de répondre directement cette
question là vu que moi encore une fois
je suis journaliste l'idée c'est quand
même d'exposer la situation telle que je
la vois par rapport aux informations que
j'ai et en aucun cas d'être le
porte-parole notamment de la diplomatie
française qui a qui a ces experts là
dessus
maintenant sa chance là j'aimerais tout
d'abord revenir sur un une histoire
personnelle lors du mouvement de faire
arriver lors du mouvement vert pardon en
lorsque déjà des manifestants iraniens
étaient tués en pleine rue alors que à
l'époque il ne demandait même pas encore
la tête de ramenéi le lit suprême et du
régime j'étais invité sur le plateau
d'une émission sur France 3 qui qui
s'est arrêté depuis ce qui s'appelle Ce
soir ou jamais qui s'appelait Ce soir ou
jamais
j'étais mon plus jeune 2009 donc 2023
moins de 2009 est égal à 14
j'avais 24 ans
et j'étais super motivé du feu de Dieu
par rapport à ce qui se passait par
rapport au mouvement
qui était héroïque déjà à son époque en
Iran et je me souviens que sur le
plateau j'avais souligné
le courage du président français de
l'époque Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait été
eu des mots très très ferme vis-à-vis de
l'élection iranienne du président élu
amadinejade au contraire d'un Barack
Obama à l'époque président des
États-Unis lui qui s'était quand même
contenté enfin qui avait gardé une
certaine manière le silence en mécanique
qui n'avait pas soutenu
expressément les manifestants ce que
beaucoup d'Iraniens lui ont reproché
d'ailleurs ce que lui-même a avoué avoué
que c'était une erreur il y a quelques
mois
quand on regarde les faits quand on se
focalise sur les faits
que je le sentiment qu'avec un peu de
recul Barack Obama n'a pas eu forcément
tort parce que le fait de tendre la main
au mot là à l'époque
le négociations nucléaire avec lui à mon
sens plus déstabilisé la République
islamique à l'époque
que les redomontas de Nicolas Sarkozy
qui n'ont eu en tout cas aucun effet sur
la question de la répression du
mouvement vert de l'époque
et ceci pour une raison simple la France
tu es une grande puissance mais au moins
une Orient elle compte aujourd'hui moins
elle est con elle est qualifiée par les
puissances sur place de puissance
moyenne
qui n'a peut-être plus le rôle qu'elle a
pu avoir pu jouer à l'époque de Jacques
Chirac le président Chirac ou du général
de Gaulle
tout ça pour dire quoi pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui on entend énormément de
critiques qui sont fondées sur la
position française vis-à-vis de l'Iran
de la répression
mais rien n'est véritablement simple
on les comprend elles sont je pense
justifier ces critiques quand on parle
aux Iraniens de la diaspora mais
également quand on parle
aux défenseurs des droits de l'homme en
Iran ou à l'étranger qui disent qu'en
France et que plus globalement en
Occident on en fait pas assez
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé ce
que la France a fait au cours des
derniers mois bon il y a certains
symboles déjà qui peuvent choquer
comme celui de la fameuse poignée de
main du président de la République
Emmanuel Macron avec le président
ultra conservateur Ibrahima ici qui a eu
le lundi alors que les manifestations
avaient commencé déjà le jeudi
pour un président qui aime
beaucoup le coup médiatique pour cette
constater que celui-là ne lui a pas
forcément rendu service
maintenant en même temps
notre président a voulu certainement
laver cette affront en recevant et en
étant le premier chef d'État occidental
à recevoir
dans le palais de l'Élysée 4 militantes
et
Ferrari la reconnu
leur évolution c'était une première
quand il exploité quand ils sont
expliqués le lendemain sur France Inter
alors là on est revenu un peu dans le
même temps présidentiel c'est-à-dire
qu'il a déclaré que les valeurs que
défendaient les Iraniennes étaient des
valeurs qui ne concernaient tous
universaliste qu'il se devait de saluer
cette révolution en mots très important
qui est d'ailleurs provoqué l'IR de
terrain mais qu'en même temps il devait
continuer à discuter négocier avec les
autorités iraniennes pour régler une
crise
très importante au lieu aux yeux de la
communauté internationale notamment de
l'Occident la crise du nucléaire iranien
aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous
quatre salles de sanction ont été
prononcées par le biais de l'Union
européenne à l'unanimité contre des
Gardiens de la Révolution pas les
gardiens de révolution mais des Gardiens
de la Révolution
contre des personnalités impliquées
d'autres personnalités impliquées dans
la répression des membres
de vos dirigeants de la police des mœurs
des membres de la télévision d'État des
responsables de la télévision d'État en
Iran
il y a ce débat
qui est mis en avant en premier lieu par
les opposants iraniens de l'intérieur
mais également de l'extérieur de placer
d'aller jusqu'au bout des choses des
choses pardon et de placer les Gardiens
de la révolution de l'armée l'idéologie
de la République islamique sur la liste
européenne des organisations terroristes
vous rappelez que Donald Trump a déjà
fait
en 2018 lorsqu'il s'est retiré de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
que ça a été très mal ressenti et c'est
normal par les autorités iraniennes mal
considérer mais que cela n'a pas pour
autant arrêter l'action des Gardiens de
la révolution qui restent omniprésents
dans la répression en Iran dans les
activités économiques du pays ils ont
entre leurs mains deux tiers de
l'économie mais également au-delà des
frontières iraniennes où ils ont on
dispose d'une force la force à haute
qui organise de nombreux opérations à
l'étranger qui seront également
coupables nombreux assassinats
d'opposants
pour l'instant quand on parle quand on
discute s'il y avait beaucoup d'espoir
il y a une résolution votée par le
Parlement européen et parlementaires qui
ont pris leur courage à deux mains qui
ont à une écrasante majorité votée en
faveur de la désignation donc ils ont
appelé les instituts les institutions
européennes notamment le Conseil
européen a placé les Gardiens de la
révolution sur la glisse européenne des
organisations terroristes
malheureusement trois jours plus tard
quatre jours plus tard pardon pour
l'instant en tout cas le chef de la
diplomatie européenne le Haut
représentant aux affaires
extérieurs et en politique de sécurité
Joseph Borel a décidé de ne pas décider
ou plutôt il a
expliquer qu'il n'était pas de son
ressort
certains y voir un prétexte mais il
n'était pas dans le sable de son ressort
de placer les gardiens de révolution sur
cette sur cette liste et qu'il fallait
au préalable avoir
plein de déposés par une autorité
compétente de l'un des 28
pour ensuite que le Conseil européen
donc l'Union européenne sans cesse et
derrière que cette question soit
discutée entre les 28 membres
une décision qui doit être prise à
l'unanimité de tous les membres il y a
dans cette
certains ont dit que c'était un prétexte
c'était grossier et que l'on m'a appelé
layette au Laborel ou le gardien de la
Révolution Borel bon c'est un peu simple
à mon avis mais bon
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il a présenté
il y a aujourd'hui on sait des pays qui
sont favorables y compris les pays qui
auparavant était beaucoup plus proche
avec l'Iran comme l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui ils sont pour cette
reconnaissance il y a d'autres pays dont
le nôtre la France mais également la
Belgique qui sont plus timorées par
rapport à cette possibilité
officiellement la raison quand on en
parle quand on demande aux diplomates
mais pourquoi mais
ils nous disent
placer les Gardiens de la révolution sur
la liste européenne des organisations
terroristes c'est couper dernière canal
de communication c'est une rupture
vis-à-vis de l'Iran coupé notre dernier
canal de communication
avec les ayatollas avec la révolution
mais surtout donc avec les toilettes
donc les autorités iraniennes
or
c'est par hasard il y a une crise qui
glisse déjà depuis de nombreuses années
qui pointent encore plus le bout de son
nez pour l'été prochain c'est le
nucléaire pour résumer
il y a 21 ans on a pris Clément avant un
programme secret
des négociations ont été entamées il y a
eu des accords
parfois respectés par les vents souvent
d'ailleurs quand les Français sur le
caisson nucléaire isoé puis derrière il
y a souvent des administrations
américaines que ce soit celle de George
à l'époque puis celle de Donald Trump
qui s'est retiré de ses accords
aujourd'hui comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure la stratégie notre Trump est
un échec l'Iran n'a jamais été aussi
proche de la bombe atomique l'Iran est
une puissance du seuil
bon parlons bien de nucléaire
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il y a
deux solutions pour la crise du
nucléaire iranien il y a soit un accord
et qui dit accord dit une poignée de
main entre dirigeants occidentaux et
représentant de la République islamique
pour à nouveau réduire considérablement
l'arsenal nucléaire iranien ou alors pas
d'accord si c'est pas d'accord c'est
soit la bombe iranienne comme le disait
Kushner à son époque soit le
bombardement encore faut-il que le
bombardement soit efficace et que des
pays souhaitent bombarder l'Iran pour
avoir eu des discussions avec des
diplomates américaines à ce sujet là
pour l'instant les Américains en tout
cas d'après ce qu'ils nous disent
peut-être qu'il nous manque mais ils
sont pas du tout motivés ni pour
bombarder lire en ni pour faire la
guerre entre l'Iran en raison notamment
des expériences et les précédents
catastrophiques en Irak et en
Afghanistan
donc là dessus ce qui est intéressant
encore une fois n'est pas la première
qui a raison qui a tort c'est que avec
la question de nucléaire les Iraniens
ont un maître argument pour faire
chanter les occidentaux sur la question
de la répression ça veut pas dire que
cela est impossible
certains pays ont pris leur
responsabilité sous la pression
notamment de la diaspora iranienne
présente en nombre pour preuve le Canada
qui récemment
a décidé de sanctionner 10 000 personnes
et activités d'entités liées au gardien
de la révolution sur son territoire ce
qui veut dire ce qui signifie que malgré
les sanctions américaines les Gardiens
de la Révolution
contiennent mieux à contourner les
sanctions internationales les sanctions
américaines par le biais de société
écran notamment situé
au Canada
revenons à la France
je ne vais peut-être en heure en heurté
certains
d'entre vous
en disant qu'en dépit et la France est
présente et même les médias français moi
je trouve personnellement en tant que
journaliste que les médias français que
l'opinion publique française
et quand même au rendez-vous par rapport
à ce qui se passe en Iran bien sûr on
voudrait plus et il faut qu'il y ait
plus ça je dis cette fois en tant
qu'hiernien casquette iranienne
mais la situation est loin d'être simple
les Gardiens de la Révolution le savent
très très bien
les menaces proférées par le général
salami sans mauvais jeu de mots j'en ai
parlé mais c'est vrai que le chat des
gars de la Révolution s'appelle le
général salami a déclaré suite au
caricatures de Charlie Hebdo
que les Français
et que les dessinateurs de Charlie Hebdo
devait faire très attention car elle
pourrait subir le même sort que ça ne me
russe dit dont la fatwa prononcée à
l'époque parle little Romania a quand
même été
exercé en tout cas une des conséquences
a été le fait qu'il soit poignardé cet
été aux États-Unis
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
les autorités françaises les services de
sécurité Français savent très bien que
les Gardiens de la révolution sont une
armée étatique il disposent de moyens
considérables notamment en raison des
ressources iraniennes pétrole gaz qui
ils ont toutes les plus grandes
difficultés du monde à pouvoir les
exporter ils atteignent quand même ces
derniers mois des exportations au niveau
record d'exploitation notamment grâce
aux achats effectués par la Chine et les
pays
dans son voisinage direct
rien ne pourrait empêcher alors en tout
cas c'est pas une menace mais c'est ce
que j'imagine j'imagine avoir honte
peut-être que j'ai tort mais rien
n'empêche pourrait empêcher les Gardiens
de la révolution de commettre des
attentats
en Europe ils l'ont déjà fait contre les
touristes ou d'anciens diplomatis
israélien
ils ont même réussi
en il y a 3 ans à attirer dans un piège
un journaliste iranien joue au lasagne
qui avait une chaîne télégramme
extrêmement puissante qui était suivi
par des dizaines des centaines de
milliers d'Iraniens ils ont réussi à
l'attirer dans un piège en utilisant
d'ailleurs
une femme
pour l'attirer femme membre du régime
pour l'attirer dans un piège en Irak où
il a été enlevé ramené de force en Iran
condamné à l'issue d'un simulacre de
procès pendu
tout cela pour dire que les relations
entre la France et l'Iran elles sont
tumultueuses et nul n'est censé oublier
que dans les années 1980
les Iraniens par le biais de relais
notamment libanais le groupe
djihadistes officiellement qui n'a rien
à voir avec l'Iran ils ont perpétré des
attentats sur le sol français à Paris
attentat tatie
à l'époque pour récupérer ce qu'ils
estimaient être leur du suite à une
affaire de non-paiement par la France
non remboursement de l'argent
qu'il avait versé le chat pour avoir des
parts dans un cours de consortium pardon
nucléaire qui s'appelait Eurodif bref
également en raison du soutien français
à Saddam Hussein lors de la guerre Iran
Irak et notamment de la livraison de
super étendaires tout ça pour dire quoi
pour dire que la situation est loin
d'être facile
on parle on peut également et c'est ce
que demande beaucoup d'Iraniens avec
lesquels on discute depuis les ans c'est
des gestes au moins symboliques pour
assurer ce qu'on appelle un prix à payer
vous exécutez contre
norme judiciaire et légale des
manifestants qu'on a ici de simulacre le
procès leur faire payer le prix pour
qu'ils aient pour qu'ils réfléchissent
ils y réfléchissent à deux fois avant
d'exécuter
un prochain manifestant
une réalité
c'est que la République islamique fait
très attention
et très perméable aux pression
extérieure
ils l'ont montré durant
durant l'histoire récente ne faut pas
oublier que d'après les services de
renseignement occidentaux le jour où la
République islamique a officiellement
pas officiellement ce qu'ils n'ont
jamais reconnu mais en tout cas mis un
terme à leur recherche et leurs
activités
militaires pour avoir la bombe atomique
ça a été 2003 au lendemain de l'invasion
de l'Irak par George Bush il craignait
vraiment d’être les prochains sur la
liste je ne suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut refaire ça pas du tout mais
que la pression fonctionne
comment se fait-il une question que je
pose que jusqu'ici
dans un geste symbolique coordonné et
simultané les 28 n'est pas décidé de
retirer leurs ambassadeurs
pour protester contre
la répression sans précédent des
manifestations comment fait-il par
ailleurs qu'il ait fallu attendre trois
mois
pour que le charger d'affaires parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'ambassadeur pour
l'instant il a dit à Paris le chargé
d'affaires iranien soit convoqué au
cadorset
forcément arrive à ce moment-là la
question des otages
aujourd'hui en France on a 7 otage celle
de nos ressortissants qui sont détenus
en Iran qui ont été arrêtés depuis 2019
de façon arbitraire et qui servent au
régime de monnaie des changes soit dans
les moments comme ça pour obtenir
non pas officiellement et pour suggérer
que la France devrait mieux garder le
silence
si elle espère revoir un jour c'est
ressortissant c'est pas dit directement
mais c'est ça suggère ou alors pour
récupérer des prisonniers iraniens
détenus diplomates espions accusé
d'avoir contourné les sanctions ou
accuser de terrorisme condamné même pour
terroriser c'est le cas d'un diplomate
espion belge à ceux de leur Assadi
condamné par un tribunal d'Anvers en
2021 à 20 ans de prison pour une
tentative d'attentat avortée contre un
rassemblement d'opposants iraniens en
France sur le sol français
donc voilà c'est une partie qui est loin
d'être facile
on en parlait hier c'est très
intéressant avec la députée européenne
Nathalie Loizeau ancienne diplomate qui
racontait qui nous expliquait
qu'il est toujours nécessaire d'avoir
des liens pour savoir pour essayer
d'aider les manifestants en ayant des
yeux des oreilles sur place quand ils
ont besoin de l'aide de la France
les Iraniens quand ils vous ont besoin
de visa parce que nous expliquer et que
peut-être que symboliquement ça serait
forme et que dans les faits
effectivement ça n'aurait aucun impact
aucun impact et c'était une mesure
peut-être qu'on pourrait qualifier de
populistes de demander de solliciter
ceci donc pour revenir là-dessus la
situation est très difficile elle est
très compliqué vous prendrons en compte
tous les les éléments que je vous ai
donné
aujourd'hui en tout cas on peut voir du
côté de l'administration
américaine comme de l'aide donc de Joe
Biden comme de l'administration donc la
le gouverne comme de la part du
gouvernement français et du président
Macron un souhait de ne pas totalement
fermer la porte à l'Iran preuve en est
l'Iran par exemple été invité à des
conférences régionales
qui s'appelait Bagdad et Bagdad 2 qui
est organisé à Man on parlait justement
des questions régionales au cours de ces
discussion diplomate iranien
ont pu s'entretenir avec des diplomates
saoudiens et diplomates français les
Français auront répété leur souhait de
voir les otages être libérés mais c'est
la complexité voilà c'est la complexité
la complexité de la de la situation
maintenant une dernière chose et c'est
pas pour être pessimiste du tout juste
pour parler
des précédents
il faut pas que les Iraniens oublient
que qui sont en France ou en Iran
que
malheureusement en dépit de toute la
répression
aveugle du massacre de son propre peuple
Bachar el-Assad
a pu rester au pouvoir
grâce également
à parfois l'incohérence de certains pays
occidentaux contrairement à d'autres
pays comme la Russie et l'Iran qui dès
le premier jour était sur place et où
lui ont dit tu peux compter sur nous on
t'aidera jusqu'au bout ce qu'ils ont
fait
il est quand même 500 000 morts
en Syrie on en est pas du tout pour
l'instant la même échelle en Iran on en
est officiellement officiellement
officieusement pardon à 500 500 510 520
voilà toutes les données que l'on a
maintenant bien évidemment
que je pense qu'il est indispensable
encore une fois qui est un message
envoyé un prix à payer
on va y aller aux Iraniens qui sont
encore une fois très sensibles
aux remarques qui peuvent venir de
l'Occident d'autant que l'Iran c'est
très bien que au-delà des grandes
déclarations sur les accords
de 25 ans noués avec la Chine future
collaboration enfin collaboration
militaire qui a déjà lu avec la Russie
elle aura toujours besoin de l'Occident
pour développer
son industrie qui a besoin de la
technologie ou occidentale et qui
aujourd'hui on est privé du fait des
sanctions américaines
merci beaucoup Armin
j'apparacte tu voulais rebondir et je te
laisserai enchaîner pour présenter le
collectif je rebondis juste sur un
aspect qui me paraît important c'est que
il me semble que toutes ces
problématiques n'existent aujourd'hui
que parce que nous sommes en présence de
la République islamique certains disent
même en Iran pas dire et que
si on continue comme on le fait depuis
43 ans à courber les Chine et à
continuer ses discussions et ses
négociations en se disant allez on
temporise on ne fait que reculer pour
mieux sauter parce qu'il y a un moment
ou un autre ou de toute façon cette
politique de la terreur qui qui est mise
en oeuvre vers l'extérieur elle continue
elle continuera à être appliquée par
l'Iran par par le régime actuel et donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si on
continue
et qu'on ne fait rien et qu'on ne prend
pas des mesures fermes il y aura
toujours des otages en Iran et il y aura
toujours besoin de négocier pour des
accords qui seront alors sur ce coup là
effectivement à l'époque c'était pas
l'Iran qui avait manqué à ses
obligations mais très franchement
aujourd'hui avec le visage que l'on
connaît à ce régime qui peut imaginer
une seconde qu'il soit digne de
confiance et n'apprend-t-on pas de nos
erreurs
on est regardé où on se trouve
aujourd'hui après avoir fait confiance
au
talibanez le pauvre état dans lequel se
trouve les femmes dans ce pays alors que
soi-disant des garanties avaient été
donnés donc
j'entends et je comprends qu'on essaie
de prendre un peu de recul et de se dire
voilà on peut pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi évidemment nous on nous
ne sommes pas ceux qui appuient sur sur
le bouton mais
quelque part
quand on continue ces discussions et
quand on temporise comme on entre on ne
fait que temporiser et tôt ou tard ça
pèlera et donc soit on continue d'avoir
dans le monde d'accepter qu'il existe
dans le monde un régime comme celui-ci
qui en plus à des tentacules qui
nourrissent le Liban dont on ne va pas
parler assez je trouve parce que voilà
et puis je peux vous dire que nous nous
sommes tous dit on prend un risque on
prend un risque on sait qu'on va plus
pouvoir retourner chez nous mais le
risque il est bien plus proche en fait
les risques et les menaces qu'on a eu
elles sont au pied de nos portes ce sont
des gens qui travaillent qui travaillent
dans des gros groupes ce sont des gens
qui travaillent
auprès des organisations spatiales qui
nous ont menacé ce sont des gens qui
bossent dans les banques internationales
qui sont en charge des sanctions qui
nous ont menacé ils sont haut placé ils
sont partout d'accord donc je pense qu'à
un moment donné
quand on dit qu'il faut les étouffer il
faut les étouffer parce que si on ne les
étouffe pas ils vont continuer à grandir
et je ne sais pas si ensuite on arrivera
à les étouffer voilà donc ça c'était
juste
[Applaudissements]
après
sur un sujet beaucoup plus léger mais
pas tant que ça je voudrais donc vous
présenter notre association puisque
aujourd'hui nous sommes une association
fait Amazonie
et nous sommes neufs comme comme on vous
l'a dit neuf Franco iranienne
aujourd'hui nous sommes 6 présentes ici
si vous voulez bien vous lever celles
qui sont pas sur la sur l'estrade voilà
[Applaudissements]
et vous voyez on n'est pas très
impressionnant mais on a fait pas mal de
choses et c'est ça dont je voudrais vous
parler et je voudrais ce dont on est
très heureuse et nos frustrations aussi
pour que vous sachiez ce dont on a
besoin donc voilà on s'est rencontré
c'est une rencontre qui s'est faite sur
Instagram donc une rencontre des temps
modernes
moi mon Instagram avant très franchement
c'était kim Kardashian démaquilleuse
parce que c'était mon échappatoire de ma
vie professionnelle qui est déjà très
lourde et puis aujourd'hui alors j'ai
que des gens avec des balles exploser
c'est plus du tout le même le même le
même Instagram on s'est rencontré comme
ça on a décidé au tout début qu'on
allait unir nos forces en créant une
association dont le but serait d'alerter
les médias qui à l'époque étaient très
silencieux au tout début on voyait rien
et c'était une frustration énorme
bon Armin a toujours très bien fait son
travail
mais voilà c'était c'était vraiment très
frustrant pour nous dire mais il se
passe des choses abominables et c'est
même pas une ligne il y avait rien nulle
part dans aucun j'étais même dans les
chaînes de nous de news qui tourne tout
le temps donc on voulait faire ça et on
a voulu aussi on s'est dit le premier
soutien c'est le peuple français il faut
qu'il sache ce qui se passe ils pourront
pas être indifférents à ce qui se passe
et donc on a fait une vidéo avec une
grande ambition qui était de faire je
passe en mille vu et cette vidéo a fait
10 millions de vues elle a été partagée
par Juliette Binoche Sophie Marceau BHL
Carla Bruni enfin un jour j'ai même dit
on est on a ça d'Angelina Jolie ça n'est
pas arrivé mais donc c'était les défis
et donc voilà c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on
a commencé et on vous propose pour
j'espère que certains d'entre vous ne
l'ont pas vu mais de la visionner
quelques instants
allô le monde vous nous entendez ici le
pape iranien savez-vous ce qui se passe
chez nous en ce moment tout a commencé
avec la mort de Marsa Gina Amini une
jeune femme pure de 22 ans battue à mort
par la police des mœurs le 16 septembre
dernier son crime une mèche de cheveux
dépassant de son voile tu te demandes
comment est-ce possible en 2022 et bien
cela s'appelle la République islamique
d'Iran un régime sanguinaire qui sévit
dans notre pays depuis 43 ans et contre
lequel on lutte depuis les iraniennes
ont dit assez elles se sont levées
telles une armée les Iraniens ont suivi
et tout un peuple a décidé de lutter
contre l'obscurantisme manifestation et
grève ont envahi le pays gonflant notre
cœur d'espoir de retrouver notre terre
libre de mettre fin à ce régime barbare
et terroriste
le soldat de la liberté s'appelle
battue à mort pour avoir réclamé la
liberté sa mère n'a pas pu supporter
elle s'est suicidé Nico chocalami 16 ans
enterrait le jour de ses 17 ans battu à
mort pour avoir crié sa douleur à 19
filles 20 ans tu es de 6 balles par la
police pour avoir osé manifester
mort pour n'avoir pas chanter à la
gloire du régime islamique et des
centaines d'autres
[Musique]
sais-tu que chez nous les journalistes
les intellectuels les étudiants les
sportifs les avocats les cinéastes les
minorités religieuses sont envoyées en
prison pour y subir les pires tortures
et tenter de teindre leur érudition
cette prison s'appelle Evin elle a été
brûlée il y a quelques jours au lieu de
sauver nos lumières le régime a envoyé
ses hommes leur tirer dessus les gazés
les battre tout en empêchant les secours
d'y accéder pour s'assurer de faire un
maximum de victimes et oui car en Iran
c'est la police qui tue et les
intellectuels qui sont emprisonnés
sais-tu que pour avoir klaxonné lors
d'une manifestation un homme a été tué
je te présente sa fille tu pleures
[Musique]
sais-tu quand un jour dans une seule vie
ils ont tué 87 personnes dont 7 enfants
sais-tu qu'ils ont attaqué des écolières
qui refusaient de chanter leur
propagande au sein même de leur école et
les ont battus atrocement
trois en sont mortes et une dans le coma
sais-tu qu'ils ont légalisé le mariage à
9 ans pour les petites filles qui
l'appliquent des femmes les tuent
impunément et si elles ont le malheur
d'être vierge les viols la veille de
leur exécution car ne pas tuer une
vierge
mais tu sais nous n'avons pas toujours
vécu ainsi nous sommes l'un des berceaux
de la civilisation un peuple millénaire
instruit moderne et laïque nous avons
même créé les premiers droits de l'homme
les femmes iraniennes ont toujours été
fortes intelligentes courageuse et
déterminée tu te demandes sûrement ce
que tu peux bien y faire figure-toi
qu'on te demande même pas de Camille ni
même d'accueillir chez toi des réfugiés
et encore moins de faire la guerre on te
demande juste de partager cette vidéo je
t'en supplie de détourne pas le regard
de notre combat soit notre voix les mots
là ont pris internet pour massacrer à
huis clos tu as le pouvoir de changer ça
nous manifestons inlassablement chaque
semaine à travers le monde pour qu'on
nous entende les dirigeants occidentaux
doivent reconnaître le régime islamique
comme organisation terroriste rompre
tout lien diplomatique et reconnaître
une révolution est en cours
femme vie liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ça c'était au mois d'octobre vous
voyez on est quasiment constante puisque
nous revendications n'ont pas changé
elles sont désormais portées partout
donc après cette vidéo
qu'a t'ont fait d'autres des manifs des
rassemblements
et on essaye aussi avec un autre
collectif
on est main dans la main qui s'appelle
le collectif Action foryron de réaliser
des mises en scène des exactions parce
que c'est très frappant pour le peuple
français quand il voit ça dans les rues
on a notamment organisé une d'entre
elles devant l'Assemblée nationale et
également une action coup de poing qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit avec les Femen
alors évidemment ça peut ça ne plaît pas
à tout le monde mais c'est parfois aussi
le but parce que c'est ça qui qui fait
qu'on en parle
puisque cette vidéo elle a été partagée
par brut et qu'elle a fait près de 3
millions
l'association est aussi à l'origine de
l'inscription femme vie liberté sur la
Tour Eiffel puisque c'est une demande
que l'on a faite plusieurs mois en amont
et qu'on a réussi à obtenir
Dani dalgo il y a de ça quelques temps
et puis on a parlé en long large et en
travers de 9 le château donc je ne vais
pas y revenir
mais sachez que voilà ça reste un de nos
petits points de frustration et on a
bien entendu que vous alliez nous
épauler là-dessus et donc on vous a bien
entendu
on essaie de sensibiliser la presse et
les médias donc voilà dès qu'on a eu
l'occasion on a pris la parole pour pour
faire entendre ce qui se passe on
collabore avec avec la boîte de prod
lignes de front avec abyssinnews et avec
eBay
et on a évidemment aussi essayer de
sensibiliser les politiques alors aucune
d'entre nous
ne vient de ce monde là on avait toutes
des vies comme disait Aurélie normal
avec des maris ou pas des enfants ou pas
un métier mais personne n'avait jamais
fait le moindre acte politique et donc
notre première étape quand même parce
qu'on a qu'on s'est dit on commence pas
petit on a fait des lettres à la
ministre des Affaires étrangères madame
Colonna et on s'est dit on va être un
peu casse-pied donc on en a fait signer
plein lors d'une manif mais on a tout
fait manuellement donc elle a reçu je
pense 200 lettres et elle pouvait pas
identifier enfin elle ou la pauvre
personne qui travaille pour elle et donc
il fallait vraiment les ouvrir une à une
et donc nos demandes étaient déjà celles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui on a ensuite
fait cette cette lettre ouverte à
Emmanuel Macron pour laquelle encore une
fois je tiens à remercier
les personnes qui sont aussi présente
donc Aurélie Trottin mode Gatel
Anne-Caroline vert et Isabelle Floren
puisque elles nous ont soutenu dès cette
première étape alors que certains
disaient ah mais vous demandez le rappel
où
enfin je sais plus c'était le rappel ou
la convocation de l'ambassadeur c'est
beaucoup trop ambitieux et puis elles
ont lancé le mouvement on a été ça a été
parmi les premiers signataires de notre
lettre qui a été très largement relayée
en fait même au sein de la majorité on a
eu beaucoup de députés on a eu beaucoup
de maires on a eu aussi beaucoup
d'artistes alors je vous en nommer
quelques-uns Florence Foresti Marjane
Satrapi Camélia Jordana des footeux
Robert pierres ça c'était ma petite
victoire perso donc j'aime bien insister
sur celle là
alors on demandait si mesures dans cette
lettre et je veux vous en parler parce
que vous allez voir que on garde le fil
on demandait que l'ambassadeur de France
en Iran soit rappelé ou à tout le moins
convoqué on nous disait mais comment
c'est impossible bon le rappel n'a pas
encore eu lieu la convocation si et donc
on va dire que c'est une moitié de
réussite après plusieurs mois d'attentes
on demandait que des mesures concrètes
soient prises pour que soit exigée
l'exclusion de la République islamique
d'Iran de la Commission de la condition
de la femme de l'ONU ça c'est fait on
demandait que des mesures soient prises
pour qu'il y ait une enquête au sein de
l'ONU ça aussi c'est fait
on demandait l'inscription du corps des
Gardiens de la révolution sur la liste
des organisations terroristes c'est un
peu fait puisque le Parlement européen
comme on le disait à
largement soutenu ça et je vous en
redirai un petit mot tout à l'heure en
revanche comme on l'a dit comme Marvin
l'a dit ça a bloqué au niveau de Borel
et ensuite donc du Conseil de l'Union
européenne
on a demandé aussi une résolution qu'une
résolution condamne la République
islamique d'Iran au sein de l'ONU ça
c'est pas encore fait non plus et on a
demandé mais ça on sait que c'est plus
long mais on sait que ça arrivera que le
nécessaire soit fait pour qu'un jour
tous ces bourreaux puissent être jugés
devant la Cour internationale de Justice
donc ça ça prendra un peu plus de temps
on en est conscient le reste on est très
impatient alors
[Musique]
donc ça a été un moment très intense
autre action politique qu'on a mené
c'était justement au moment où les
discussions allaient avoir lieu au sein
du Parlement européen beaucoup de
parlementaires européens faisaient
l'écho et nous on recevait ça des
députés ici en fait on n'a pas les
outils on n'a pas les arguments enfin
les informations sont difficiles à
obtenir que peut-on répondre si jamais
on nous dit tel ou telle chose et donc
on a fait une note très détaillée qu'on
a distribué à tous les parlementaires
français européen encore une fois qu'ils
soient PPE réunion enfin bref tous les
tous les parlementaires européens et on
sait que certains d'entre eux ce qui
nous l'ont dit sans son servis pour
convaincre d'autres parlementaires au
sein de leur groupe donc voilà ça
c'était une une belle victoire même si
elle a porté ses fruits mais pas
jusqu'au bout et donc s'est passé
toujours notre attente et nous en fait
ces actions les mènent ici parce qu'on
se sent enfin vous voyez on était tous
endormis pendant 43 ans
pendant 43 ans on faisait pas grand
chose on vivait nos plus belles villes
ici en Europe et on savait que voilà on
avait des cousins cousines qui avaient
pas cette chanson en Iran et puis avec
la main de ma famille on a beaucoup qui
disent qu'elle s'est endormie et que
tout un peuple s'est réveillé c'est
vraiment ça qui s'est passé pour pour
nous toutes et on a décidé qu'on pouvait
pas rester juste bien au chaud dans nos
démocraties et qu'il fallait que nous si
eux prenaient ce risque là à l'intérieur
du pays qu'on se bouge ici aussi pour
faire changer les choses j'ai oublié de
mentionner une action importante que je
vais mentionner pardon qui est que et
là-dessus n'a obtenu du soutien de mode
encore une fois
on a été alerté sur le fait que les
balles qui étaient utilisées
contre le peuple en Iran par les
gardiens de la révolution était des
balles de fabrication franco-italienne
qui était donc envoyé en Iran nonobstant
l'ex de sanctions qui interdisent de
telles choses et donc voilà
les questions étaient posées au
gouvernement à cet égard et et on espère
que ça avancera dans le bon sens
il y a une chose où on a un peu menti
dans notre vidéo mais on savait pas un
que ça allait durer aussi longtemps
puisque nous étions très très très
persuadés que ça allait très vite et la
chose sur laquelle nous avons un petit
peu menti c'est qu'on vous disait on
veut pas de cagnotte on n'a pas besoin
d'argent et en fait on se rend compte
que quand le combat est long comme le
nôtre finalement il y a un moment donné
où le financement devient nécessaire et
donc ce qu'on a fait déjà dans le passé
c'est qu'on a vendu des tas de bagues
des t-shirts et qu'on a utilisé ces
fonds pour acheter des VPN aujourd'hui
comme le disait il y a les VPN c'est
plus c'est pas c'est plus trop
d'actualité ça ne fonctionne pas
forcément en revanche des fonds sont
toujours nécessaires pour pouvoir
envoyer par des modes je vous ne vous le
cache pas détourner des médicaments des
vêtements de l'alimentation
là comme vous l'avez peut-être entendu
il y a une région qui a été secouée par
des séismes
au lieu de les aider le régime donc ce
sont des gens qui se retrouvent à la rue
il faut savoir qu'en Iran il fait très
froid il neige là et au lieu de les
aider les asperges d'eau glacées donc
voilà c'est ça qu'on aimerait pouvoir
faire c'est aider de ce point de vue là
on apporte aussi nos soutiens notre
soutien pardon à des réfugiés qui
arrivent en France quand ils sont voilà
avec des situations compliquées je crois
qu'il y a on l'a pas dit mais il y a est
arrivé à deux trois semaines enfin voilà
c'est assez récent
et donc
voilà les vous avez vu on a des tas de
bagues on a des
une possibilité de faire des dons à
l'assaut et tout ce qu'on pourra dégager
de ça nous aidera à mener nos actions
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment à tous les cinq pour
ces échanges pour vos témoignages
c'était une table ronde je pense assez
bouleversante on se doutait un peu de ce
qui se passait parce que voilà on avait
un petit aperçu le témoignage d'Ilia et
vraiment enfin voilà c'est c'est honteux
c'est après voilà comme l'expliquait
Armin il y a des enjeux donc on verra ce
que ça donne en tout cas plein d'espoir
pour le peuple iranien encore une fois
félicitations pour tout ce que vous
faites mesdames et on est à vos côtés
comme on dit Isabelle et Maud on est à
vos côtés depuis le début et on continue
merci beaucoup merci à tous pour votre
présence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]